hello everybody aloha hello so i was like oh my god oh my
god that's the third loop i gotta start now i was like oh
it's the third loop oh no wait i was like chowing down my
lunch my by the way it's okay it sounds very sad my
microwave my microwaved reheated steak i got my leftover
steak I got reheated in a microwave.
I was like, yum, yum, yum, yum.
That was, yeah, no, yeah, no, I know it sounds very sad.
Um, steak is steak.
Um, so I was like, I'm trying to finish as fast as I could
before, like, in the three loops.
Um, okay.
Um, well, it's not really story time, but like, uh, dad bit
me because um he got a little too excited hi robert i'm
robert again thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you so um um i was trying to get the ball and then he like
he like the ball was still in his mouth and he's like and
then he first time he's ever broke skin um it's okay we got
him rabies shots so it's okay uh my parents made sure that
he had his rabies shot so don't worry guys i can still drink
water um but like you know and then i consistently kept him
uh kept him on his shots um but yes no he's tasted blood
it's over uh yeah he started his rebellious phase um as a
middle-aged dog um but yes no um so he like bit me on the
inside like the you know the where the joy where the finger
connects to the palm um he bit me there because I was trying
to grab the ball and then, um, and then like he, uh, he was
like, Don't you know, he was like, like, like, like, so like
the, obviously he thought he was still biting on his ball,
but he would be bit my finger.
Charlie, dad bit my finger, Charlie bit my finger.
Oh my God.
I can't believe that was a fucking meme.
But we're we as a society.
9.0, daggibless super chat.
Thank you.
Today's my birthday as a barely functioning last year
getting a job and thinking about college etc and hope i can
accomplish more this year thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you i hope you have a wonderful birthday and
accomplish much more happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you happy birthday dear nano happy birthday to you yay happy
birthday also um i know like i know i'm like you guys are
like please stop talking about my revivals but my revivals
update um i talked to the organizers um and uh they might i
don't know if they will but like i might have to off-roll so
like i don't know if they are gonna do it but uh um because
like we were i was like giving suggestions on how we can
make it more fun and let's like try hard i was like oh you
could put all the eternity plus players on off-roll i'm not
playing take i swear i would fucking play would i don't care
um if we have four dps i'm playing dps um so so um um and i
said like oh i don't think it'd be we don't know what's
gonna happen like because um i i said like um oh like an
eternity player has so much more game sense map knowledge
and skill wise over a celestial player I don't know you guys
understand the gap between Celestial and Eternity.
It's actually like, no, like whenever a Celestial player
gets accidentally gets into an Eternity lobby, like they get
yelled at.
Like you could tell that they do not belong in that lobby
because like the knowledge between a Celestial player and
Eternity player is such a huge gap that like every, I know
because I play Ranks.
So every time a Celestial player sneaks into an Eternity
lobby, they always get yelled at.
try to pick dps they're like no get on support like they're
like no get on support you do not touch dps or like get off
of tick no so so because they're asking me like do you think
celestial players should also be on their off roles and i
was like i i said personally i don't know um because uh um
because like i don't know i don't know these players but i
do know that a celestial 3 player versus a celestial 1
player is also a huge gap between knowledge because you know
celestial 1 is closer to eternity versus celestial 3 who's
closer to grandmaster um especially if that's their peak if
they piece celestial 3 then like i know you've never like
hit that elo where you could play with the eternity players
or like you know sometimes you do but you know you don't
play often with eternity players so um so like you know i'm
trying to help them figure out you know as someone that
organized tournaments before i'm trying to help them
especially like for hero shooters because i think hero
shooters is the hardest thing to um is the hardest thing to
figure out in terms of like how do you balance a hero
shooter when all roles are different because it's like 70
support players in this tournament um so so how do you
balance a tournament when percent of the people you have in
this tournament are essentially support players and we have
two tier tank players there's only two tank players like
they can other support players can off-roll as tank players
but like it's still an off-roll so it's like more so of like
um how how do you how do you balance a tournament when it's
70 support players one percent tank players and the rest its
DPS.
So it's very, um, like there are, no, they have like, you
know, like second role, like, you know, like, what is your
main role and what is your second role?
Obviously your second role will never be as good as your
first role because when you're playing your second role,
you're essentially flexing, you know?
Um, so they're asking me about that.
And I said, I told them personally, I don't know.
I think for sure, um, to make it more fun, each tournament
player should off-roll and I said I don't you know how it's
like I hope I don't off-roll but if I have to to make this
tournament more fun for everyone I will even though like I
would love to play support um but I you know I understand
that like you know I will take it for the team and I'll
off-roll just so everyone can have a more fun time because
there's no reason why they them yesterday i did my placement
matches i did all 10 of my placements matches and um because
i was like i got it you know i have the practice for the
tournament um because everyone was like oh it's for fun the
prize money is 7.5k for first place um and um um anyway so i
obviously i didn't try out the new season yet and i was like
oh okay i should really see what the new meta is and like
see how to play in this new elo and also try out Gambit
because in my head I was like um in my head I was like the
only way I can carry my team as a support play is I have to
play Gambit because Gambit a lot of people are like Gambit
is the cure coat no Gambit is the honor of of Marvel rivals
um because you don't use your cleanse the only thing you do
on Gambit this is what I've learned um how to play gambit
like you know and then like all them like you have to play
like saipe who is currently who is like rank one support in
the world and saipe got rank one on gambit and basically
everyone was like um you barely use your cleanse because
what you do is you have to use your anti-heal every like all
the time it's all about anti-heal so he is basically the
honor of Marvel rivals because you're just and like and then
my friends they're like um no DPS can 1v1 a gambit anymore
because his util is so good anti-heal means when you use it
when he use it and it's like a it's like a hit scan
anti-heal too it's not even projectile the anti-heal is so
broken it does damage and it does anti and you have two so I
could technically spam two and then the supports so um so
he's so fucking strong and his dash and his dash is so good
too so i um so i did all my placement matches and um yeah he
can heal while using his mobility too so gambit is very
fucking strong right now and it's like my friends were like
who are pros are like no tps player can confidently 1v1 um
gambit and gambit anymore because he's that oh like that
good of a support and then he was like uh he's like
basically he can kill all the other supports um even if like
if he has like a if he he could pick off any support player
on the enemy team with his anti-heal and his like left click
and so so i was like that can't be true there's no way
I was like, there's no way he's that good.
Like, there's, like, oh my gosh.
Like, you know, I was like in denial.
So then I was like, I'm going to go, you know, I'm going to
go do my placement matches and then see how it's going to be
like.
And so this is like, I think this is my second placement
match.
And I need you guys to know, this was in a lobby of GM1s and
celestial players and top 500 is celestial 2 right now and
look at this look at this stat line very carefully
oh and also look at my finalist I was it was basically a 1v1
I literally you win if I went with winning 1v1s against
spider-man and iron fist and
And I've only had One loss on gambit But and whenever I got
to play gambit.
I've only had on Gambit when I had to and I played six games
on him and so um yeah so he's like he's very strong but
Gambit is the only character I believe and Mantis is Gambit
and Mantis that you can use to no they had a Gambit but he
swapped off because he was shit like the enemy team had a
Gambit but they swapped off because obviously he wasn't
doing as good as the other gambit so it's not like so if i
could do that in a high elo lobby imagine what i could do in
like the vtuber tournament as gambit because like he is the
only character i believe that can that can confidently i can
say can actually one v for a team if i just take off angles
and we play triple support so i was telling them i was just
like oh um i feel like you know if i was on gap like maybe
they'll just ban gambit but i was just like if i was on get
gambit this is not gonna be fun also luna is hard not meta
luna is trash right now um and then um i i am confident
because me on gambit i can like I can bully the lower ELO
supports easily or the lower ELO DPS players because I was
already bullying the DPS players that were in my ELO that's
the thing I was already bullying the support and DPS players
in my ELO so yeah like if I had to go against people who are
lower ELO than me would not be fun for them so so um so they
were like yeah we might we will need you to off off roll and
i was like i'm fine with that like i was even saying like i
don't think it's fair you put me on gambit uh i was just
like um i was just like oh i i also i like i even i was like
i don't think it's fair if you put me in Gambit like because
like Gambit is like a DPS now and if I run triple support my
two supports can just pocket the rest of the team and I can
just take off angle and play like a triple like a second DPS
or a third DPS like um like I could literally just play as a
second DPS and like his util is so fucking broken it is
basically a self-healing DPS um so he is a self-healing dps
which is already pretty scary with anti-heal
so so i was like i just feel i feel like i like if at that
point everyone in eternity plus maybe we need to off roll i
know i'm like you know maybe like i get shit on as gambit um
leon if i can play game i just don't i don't i'm just like
thinking like i don't think it's fun if i'm just like
playing gambit and all i do is just like like use all my
util to kill their supports because like that's what i was
literally doing like here in this game so i had literally i
only lost one game on gambit there all the times i got to
play him and um and so like there is potentially a chance
that um i'm gonna have to off-roll um just to make it fair
for everyone in the tournament and uh um um what if the top
five on gps offer was to then I'm gonna ban Gambit.
I have first ban.
We all, if we all have first ban, I'll just ban Gambit.
I'm not fucking giving them Gambit.
but if everyone knows that I'm gonna play Gambit, then
Gambit's just gonna be permaband for me as well.
And then, like, and then, like, what the fuck do I do?
Like, I can't hard carry as anything else but Mantis.
Like, and even then, my Mantis is not that good compared to
like because i still like i hate aiming with mantis i don't
know how to fully aim with mantis because um because like
he's uh he's like hard to penny is so strong but not really
um there's only penny players that play penny she's still
not that she's still not the strongest tanks in rivals um so
all right like i know i'm like off topic but i have to talk
also they were like if we off-roll, will you be captain
again?
And I didn't respond back.
They want to give me the captain title because I guess it
looks better if like, you know, Team Doki Bird, because they
want like, because like, the thing is, the captains, um,
they're not all the high-rank players.
It's the player, it's like basically the most well-known
VTubers are captains.
So, so like, you know, like whoever is like, more, like, you
know, the most well-known to so they they want us to like be
the face of the team like you know be the face so like you
know oh look it's this team this team this team and yeah
it's for the publicity so they're like they're like would
you be captain get we implement the off-roll thing and i'm
just like oh my gosh i really don't want to be captain i i'm
okay with being captain if i get to pick my team but like I
just feel weird about being captain.
No, it's pre-assigned.
The entire, all the teams are pre-assigned as well.
And apparently, I don't know if this is true.
I don't know.
I got a little confused.
But it was supposed to be like, oh, it's supposed to be an
all NA tournament.
And then apparently, but it wasn't that clear.
So some EU players sneaked in.
So then they were like, oh, sorry, we have to find any
players to replace you guys because you're not supposed to
be in this tournament.
Any only.
So like, they can't announce anything yet because they have
to, they have to find like any replacements.
I didn't realize it was, I think it was in the rules.
Oh yeah, I think it was, it was in the rules that it was
supposed, in the forum it was supposed to be na but like um
they didn't fully check the i guess like they didn't fully
check it um but so that's why like nothing is real it's
region lock nothing is fully yeah it wasn't said it was said
in the forum that it was na only but some eu players applied
for it so they have to like be like sorry guys it sucks it
sucks but um you know um if it's it i think it has to do
with like uh prizes as well because i know like some um
prizes like you know like transferring prize money and
everything um it has to like regarding like guidelines on
how to transfer prize money especially for taxes and
everything it makes sense to keep it within na because it
gets more complicated if you're outside of na and you have
like you have to fill in like special tax forms and stuff to
receive prize money and everything So, like, so like,
because of that, that's why I'm not surprised it's NA locked
because you don't want to deal with the headaches of, like,
the headache of trying to figure out tax money, like how to,
you know, fill out the tax forms for the prize money in
itself.
So, yeah, so I don't know when teams would be announced.
I don't know if the special rules are going to be
implemented.
I did say maybe test out the off-roll rule just in case,
like do like a practice match to see if teams are going to
be able to.
are not balanced or not because I don't know like it's so I
was looking at the forum and even I was like how do you
balance this like I'm so glad I don't have to handle the
balancing for this because looking at that forum I was just
like oh my god how do you balance this because like you guys
might be thinking like oh why don't you just find players
for all roles the thing is um to run a tournament you also
have to find people that have the viewership as well to prop
up the numbers because you know all rivals all rivals one is
to make sure that um their game is advertised to as many
people as possible so um so because of that like they want
to make it balanced to a point where like you know the
bigger streamers there's also enough balance of the bigger
streamers but you know, maybe all the bigger streamers play
support.
You know?
Like all the streamers, majority of the streamers that have
the numbers and the skill level, in the different skill
level, are support players.
So, you know, that's what can you do?
So that's what a tournament has, a lot of support players.
And it's, I, you know, I don't even know how, the fuck they
balance this it's so hard and I was literally looking at you
asking my opinion being like being like what do you do you
think do you think we should give Celestia off roll and I
was like I don't fucking know I know you turn any plus shit
off roll I know I don't know for sure you turn any plus shit
off roll because I was yeah it's so strong
um so yeah anyway ow i clapped and then hit the hit the bite
wound um anyway so that is the marvel rivals update for
today um oh yeah one more thing um i bump i when i was
playing off stream i bump you know i was bumping to other
like streamers and pro players and one streamer slash pro
was like oh dokeybird um hey dokeybird um why aren't you
streaming um like they typed in the chat in the match chat
while we were in game and then i replied back he was on the
enemy team i replied back i don't know why wasn't i
nominated i know that's so fucking petty but i was like bro
it's off stream like it's off stream at two in the morning i
can see where the fuck i want i'm so salty
it's so petty i know that's it's so petty i know that's like
bro i'm fucking gonna play like bro i have nothing no
there's no whatsoever i i gain nothing anymore and then
they're just like and then they were like oh dot dot dot
I'm valid as fuck
But like I have nothing to Yeah, there's nothing to lose But
anyway, I just didn't want to style it I was trying to
practice for I was just wanting to do my place in matches
And oh yeah And I placed Celestial 3 For those who are
wondering Top 500 is Celestial 2, and I play Celestial 3.
Thanks, Gambit.
Shout out to you, Gambit.
And for those who are wondering, like, wait, if Gambit's so
strong, why isn't he bad?
Because other characters are also very strong and scary.
Daredevil is so strong, and the must-bans, what I've
learned, is Daredevil, Scythe, Emma, Hela.
These are, like, the four top bands.
at the moment so like um so these are the four that everyone
sort of always bans which i've noticed is daredevil sidlock
emma hella because they're so scary there there's too many
strong heroes because gambit um key um the thing is to play
gambit well is that you have to have the other support also
doing a lot of healing so the gambit has to rely on the
other support to be able to do
a gambit yeah it's a gamble to play gambit because there's
also a lot of shitty gambit players
gambit um gambit there's a lot of very shitty gambit players
and they all a lot of people think you have to be a heel
like think that like um oh it's do you dps on gambit or you
be a heel bot no you have to balance between the two you
have to balance between the two but You use your ability,
your card ability to do anti-heal.
That's literally it.
You barely use it for anything else.
Like, you don't really use it for healing.
You don't use it for cleanse.
You just use it for mostly anti-heal.
Cleanse is mostly for Bucky alt or Groot alt.
That's it.
But everything else is like, you know, you use it for anti.
Anyway, let's play Dispatch.
I don't know if...
Okay, I forgot to ask.
Alright.
Okay, so we have Soundgap.
Sorry, Soundgap.
I know you waited 30 minutes.
my sound settings for dispatch so he's here to rebalance
balance it for me um because I forgot to save it it's okay
it's the last stream for it today anyway um thank you guys
afternoon stream so um I don't have to worry too much uh
about streaming way too late all right let's see here here i
think it was here but like i'll see if sound guy figures
this out uh kelly thank you super chat thank you thank you
doki is too powerful she needs to put on shackles of dps in
order to be on everyone else's power levels even super chat
thank you thank you um also people got really mad that i was
robbing mistakes we can't all always have good endings guys
this year might be like a very unlucky year for me this year
like and i'm gonna reflect that in my dispatch playthrough
um we all have to live with our consequences like not every
ending is a good ending why do you think we have criminals
do you think they're happy to be in prison like look look i
am running the i don't care if i'm heading towards a bad
ending sometimes life is like that sometimes you just live
the life where you have bad things happen to you and i'm
robert
f2p thank you for the super chat thank you thank you it's
i've been really enjoying you play this game so i'm happy to
Watch you finish it on my birthday as well.
Thank you for the super shout.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear FTP.
Yay!
Happy birthday!
Alright.
Let's go.
It's Robert time.
It's time to be Robert for another day.
If I wanted to bat, I'd just stop playing game and live my
life.
The thing is, I don't know what my choice are gonna make me,
so I gotta live with my consequences.
If I make a bad choice, fuck me.
There's no going back.
I don't purposely play knowing where my choices end up to.
I pick choices that I think is pretty funny.
Because I'm not gonna make these choices and these bad
choices in real life.
I believe you have to hang out with those fuckers.
You jealous, old man?
Of what?
Let me guess.
You get into a bar fight I'm right, right.
That's what criminals do it for.
They ruin everything.
If you're going to make me stand next to a criminal, you
could at least hurry these shit up.
Bro, you missed the 3 a.m.
tacos.
You're sick as hell.
I only want to hear this full of shit.
Well, what you missed was 3 a.m.
talk.
And despite all of that, it's nice.
I guess that was.
Sounds like my local taco bell.
We good when you're good, Mecha, man.
Engaging protocols.
Game audio can be raised.
Okay.
Sound guy, what do you think?
It's fine.
I'll just, I'll raise it just in case.
All right.
I raised it a little bit.
Now.
All reading super stable.
Here we go.
Oh.
I got a flex.
Wait, no superhero pose.
All right.
Ready for launch.
Roger that.
Gotta be a superhero.
Even though I'm retired.
My cold microwave.
wave steak now.
Oh, my girlfriend here is to support me.
Did I do it?
That's the superhero pose, not the landing one.
Bro, the landing one would have been cooler.
Bro, you know, like, the Spider-Man one?
Or, like, the Superman pose?
I thought the same, too, but I think the purple is a nice
touch.
What?
Oh, that's not supposed to happen?
Yeah, I was like, where did the purple smoke come from, bro?
Oh, Ben, that's my future boyfriend.
Don't worry, I know I have two more episodes, so I can't be
dying.
I'm not... I know he's gonna live, because there's still
episodes.
Episode 7 and 8.
Oh, shit!
Don't worry, I live this, right?
I'm just gonna be in the hospital.
The last two episodes are just a blank screen.
I'm like, in...
The last two episodes is me in purgatory.
Yeah, see, I knew I was alive.
Oh, look, there's my badass dog.
I love you.
Wait, he got more injured than me?
How long was I out?
About 14, 15 hours, I think.
Bro, he broke his arm and has a concussion, and I just have,
like...
You look worse than me.
Yeah.
It's over, brother.
I cannot recreate the Astral Pulse.
What?
Too much power.
Too small a size.
We'll just make it bigger.
Horse mean I can't make the man Mecca.
I'm not good enough, bro.
No.
No, don't say that.
I must bring down the whole team.
I believe in you.
Let's get everybody blowed up.
Hey, listen.
Bro, I believe.
As long as I believe in you, you can do anything.
It's not a literal league game, brother.
This real life.
No.
Right.
Oh, I should have been like just a minor setback.
You did your best.
I can't ask for anything else.
Thank you.
Come on, give me that.
Yeah, fisted.
I heard that big bastard crying in the bathroom.
Makes it hard to shit when someone's doing that next to you,
you know?
Pretty distracting.
Yeah.
No.
Everyone else okay?
And Vizigo?
Fine.
One thing she's good at is discipline.
appearing when people get hurt what's your deal with her you
give everyone shit but it always seems extra with vizzy
she's a liability and one of us needs to be objective when
it's clear something's going on between the two of you don't
think i don't see it it's all over do you think she likes me
wait do you think she likes me bro she's like she's like
she's bad bro and like screen pe maybe put a note in her
locker for me ha ha motherfucker but this little bit you're
doing do you think i have a shot because you wouldn't be
joking like this if you didn't have a thing for look just be
careful kid some people did black holes you reach out to
help them and they just suck you in and do whatever the
black holes do i don't know they fuck you up brother she
Fuck, she's gonna fuck me up, bro?
Your new look screams, I know some science shit, so I was
with...
Oh, we can bring it a little more?
Okay, let me double check the audio.
Real quick, sound.
Yeah, we're already up the sound a lot, so we'll just up it
a little more here.
Alright, up it a little more.
I want to take the day off.
No, really.
Bro.
I'm fine.
She's gonna fuck me up, bro?
Just throw...
Say no more.
Man, you and the infirmary.
Think about that.
I'll mull it over.
It's like he's trying to warn me about her and I'm like, yo,
you think she likes me?
He's like, bro, there's so many red flags.
And I'm like, did she actually likes me?
More enhanced.
Proceed with caution.
One sec.
What are you doing up?
Turns out, I'm completely fine.
Just sort of time traveled several hours into the future
where I feel pretty rested.
Oh, cool, yeah.
happens to me every night wish i could say the same how's
your ship going good oh she takes my ship um challenging
made worse by all the enhanced villains we're dealing with
lately enhanced villains oh the the xbox ring oh yeah i know
she had to handle his hers her ex too give us some time
roids a little down but i'm sure we can come up with
alternate power sources hey really looking forward to
tonight perfect timing yeah same um also like invisible girl
is so smart to fuck the dispatcher because that means she'll
get more jobs and get sent on the easier job congrats on
that oh they got me a gift she's so smart wait i have to
just okay i need
long line for the game drop blend in with the line to not
look like i think depression oh wait no that should be um as
the as one of the most well-known game reviewers here uh
moist owner would be the perfect one to send in i need to
pop on down to the store can someone watch there's no hr in
this department i'd refuse to believe there is an hr
entertain hops to catwell the owner's way Yeah, wait,
actually, you know what?
Let's have you in Prism.
There we go.
All right.
We need two.
It's a cat, guys.
You don't understand.
A cat needs three people to entertain.
Oh, my God.
Make a new friend.
Okay, here you go.
Wait, it's a fucking tiger.
God damn NPC.
This is you talking, Robert.
Taco shit.
Oh, I knew it.
Yeah, because Golem's really good with animals yeah we did
it yeah let's go with that i had taco this bad does many
special jobs but they're not you say you could handle spicy
food yes which is why this doesn't make sense as an excuse
but oh okay i swear to god if i get no i'm still gonna drink
it i don't care if it tears a hole in my stomach damn all
right we should not go for combat guys Why don't we do one
mobility?
Surely that helps out, right?
Oh, cyberbullying.
My asshole keeps hacking to my notes app.
He's fucking with all my stand-up comedy material.
Also, I think they have access to our secure servers.
All right, so we gotta do...
Oh, it's...
Oh, my God.
It's a medium.
Do you think I'm ready?
Guys?
Guys, am I ready for medium difficulty?
Oh, my God.
That's a huge responsibility.
I brought overall up.
Also forgot how to hack, too, so this is going to be
interesting.
Oh.
Woo!
Oh, okay.
Okay, okay, this is bad.
I gotta figure this out.
Woo!
oh shit oh wait okay i could kill him okay yeah i forgot
about that i forgot i could kill him okay guys i hope you
remember that because i did it all right uh okay exit oh my
god i can remember how to do all of this i don't okay um
left right left okay guys what was the password because i
don't Bombayer.
Up, up, down, left, right, left.
What was it?
Up, up, down, uh, left, right, left.
There you go.
We get it.
Wait, that's medium?
I swear to God, the easier ones were a lot harder.
How the fuck was that medium?
Hello?
Yes, it's that time of month again.
I mean, like, call it out with this very frequent call it.
bro this caller just calls me to you know what i believe in
depression man dip i believe in him guys because oh wait
someone who can talk there you go all right there you go
yeah your job is to talk to her and clean wait does anyone
else have good stats for this no it's only him of course
jack nut loves to talk the blazer hold down the fort okay
let's get i mean as she pays us to be well it's not I just
make it look easy so like you're actually cool he's not he's
just been gone all day so it seems like he is I'm saying
that you know she does subscribe to us she's a tier 3 self
she does buy the bonuses and everything and she tips very
well so we might as well if her the job is just cleaning her
house that's fine if someone dies because one of our heroes
is cleaning the house maybe that guy that died should have
been a tier 3 sub so he could have Skip the line.
VSK, the fight between Phenomenon, the take down the trouble
Phenomenon.
Man, he scored him.
Oh my god.
Guys, the best way?
Never meet your heroes.
Send in Phenomenon to beat up his fans.
That's the best way to take care of it.
Never meet your heroes.
Especially when they're also especially when they're very
fucking depressed dude no that's true and purple just sent
here you know what let's send let's let's wait who do we
just said phenomena man uh we'll give him a reality check
robert on my home planet when someone assumes your identity
they are considered strange and he's also very oh yeah we
ain't getting this yeah it appears i will have to express my
disappointment in him in person He got injured!
That's the thing about that fucking taco place from last
night.
Wait, we did it?
Okay, were the tacos actually good or was it just 3 a.m?
Yes.
Wait, what happened to it?
I think it was both.
Oh, he got depressed!
He didn't even show up!
He got fucking depressed!
You had one job!
They were here fast!
And he didn't even...
I even went back!
That's crazy!
leaves me but there's definitely a ghost in my house anybody
over there good at exorcisms or whatever he got yeah he got
he depressed he's he depressed his bro he was gonna meet his
fans and he's like he's like nah he literally canceled the
meet and greet now he'll really never meet him he'll never
get his meet and greet also thank you for the right thank
you thank you all right investigate the supposed haunted
house reassured the homeowner that she is not cursed um oh
by sending in the devil you know what who is she friends
with again who is melavola friends with i don't remember it
says in the i know it says oh here sonar all right the best
way the best way to investigate a haunted house house um and
to reassure the homeowner that it's not cursed is to send in
a fucking monster bat and a literal demon and be like don't
worry ghosts aren't real but demons are well ghosts are
bullshit but spirits are real can confirm we are hosting a
little roast in the mayor and he came in it's a roast but be
smart we don't want to be okay be smart Alright.
Fuck.
I don't have... Okay, Prism is smart.
Look at here.
There you go.
What's it going to be this time?
What could go wrong?
I don't write my own jokes.
Can't we hire somebody?
There's a full-on gang war happening in the warehouse.
It looks like a gang war.
Red Ring Lieutenant Prigo's unassopped a gang's from
Escalade.
Okay, so we have White Man.
And then we can have her.
You know what?
Let's get all of them.
Put everybody in.
It would be a shame if I had more stuff.
Popsa.
Yeah, fright ghosts with demons.
We all know.
In rock, in rock, paper, scissors.
Oh, phone a friend.
There we go.
I knew the vibes were off this morning, but I couldn't tell
if it was divorce vibes or shitty commute traffic vibes.
Hey, maybe she's not going to hell after all.
Whoa.
Marrying someone can send you to hell.
Yeah, what?
Yeah, but only if you marry a billionaire.
Ha!
Why?
Maybe the billionaire is like, good person he made it his
money via very legal means increasing success chance when oh
nice i reached max synergy let's go they sold their souls
maybe but what if they do a lot of charity the faction of
light needs your help to overtake the faction of darkness
how did they roleplay as the hero that was foretold okay so
it's just roleplay stands for live action roleplay but it's
not a sex thing i mean it can be dressing up and playing
pretend type shit still sounds like a sex thing it can be
you heard about those conventions all right everyone oh this
is bad everyone's resting i mean oh this is very bad
assistance his line of delivery bots appear to have gained
sentience and are attacking the city all right we a hero at
a resting who would be the best to take it here uh okay so i
was dude i'll wait a little bit first and then all right
here we go role play as a hero that's foretold i'll assume
i'm gonna take i don't know if i should take sonar and put
it yeah i'll take sonar and put him in here that's good i
know you're very you were you literally was in the hunger
game so you're gonna
He was in the Hunger Games, guys.
Wait, I gotta check this.
Okay, we'll check this first.
Okay, nice.
Yeah, I think it was a little overkill, but yay.
I finally know this.
He's a very successful actor, so I think he's fine.
Alright, I swear to God, if it somehow goes all the way
here.
okay
oh shit we have a lot of upgrades okay skill point we'll put
you know what we'll put we need more intelligent people in
our team um i can't i can't keep looking at putting it all i
think we have enough combat and mobility but what if we put
one more in combat just what if guys okay um we'll put him
in he's our all
okay oh shit okay we have to send someone here stop them
before okay we'll do these two oh it has to be defense do we
have anyone that's good on defense i'm the guy for it but
you know do you i'll wait for like a little bit more okay
he's gonna be not depressed soon there you go him okay there
we go he's fine he's not depressed that guy all right i'll
send you two in defrost the bank there you go oh i know the
defense is fresh out of depression you're going back in yeah
roleplay i think these two can be they don't think it's
cosplay when they see these two all right the yachts are
taking over the mayor's after The Yadis?
They're holding everyone's hostage.
Uh, now we have two of them for extra depression.
Rescue the hostages before they get the ransom money.
It would just...
I'm your guy.
Wait, what's this?
More?
Okay, more.
You know what, more?
Alright, there you go.
I mean, that's fine, right?
We'll just hit all of you, fucking.
Um, you know what?
We'll do these two.
I didn't mean to find all right melt the ice break the ice
let me fry them the ice i mean god damn it okay send flambay
to the frost the bank without injuring the civilians bless
okay i should have seen oh i should have oh whoops sorry
flambay we can't risk you burning trap civilians um oh i
should have noticed that before before flambay went out it's
okay i have time 18 blazer's doing a speech over the college
you will be there to hear it all right uh we can wait a
little bit not we don't have to oh we'll choose a class to
lead oh a bard we have enough we do let's lead as a bard
can't be that bad oh oh thank god i was gonna say i thought
it was oh thank god i was like i have a i know i have 20
speech right now it's barred definitely I know because sonar
went to Harvard time to freak some fuckers out all right oh
shit oh wait we're five yeah I think I said yeah I think I
definitely it was a little bit of overkill workday and I
thought he could try using the forklift another certified
forklift driver dropped entire shipment to recover what you
can okay first off let us um You know what?
We'll put you on mobility.
Everyone keeps yelling at me to stop enhancing my combat.
Bro, the kid wasn't forklift certified?
No fucking way.
He wants them destroyed, but I think there's a way to
reprogram them.
Patch up to the retreating, then reprogram them to not
attack humans.
Well, oh my gosh, we need someone smart, but we don't have
that.
Fuck.
Oh, fuck.
Guys, why?
Why did I invest in combat?
Why?
There's some activity down in the sewers.
My tenants are getting uneasy.
Can you folks look into it?
Oh, this is bad.
I don't think Flamb is coming back in time.
It's okay.
I have depression, man.
And, um, be careful.
Okay.
Be still.
Wait, the odd couple.
It should be fine.
You aren't my typical romantic companions.
We should be okay.
You know what?
No, we have to keep one of you guys up for the other task
because, oh, this is bad.
This is...
No, he's not coming back in time, guys.
He ain't coming back in time.
I have to...
It should be fine.
Okay, we have to keep the... Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Your team would fail.
Would anyone not fail?
One, two, three.
Who do I hit all the guys?
Why did I invest in all the combat?
What?
I mean, I can't even do this.
All right, some people are going to die today.
Yes, some people are going to.
All right.
Sometimes things happen.
I got it.
All right.
We have to accept that We can't save everyone I know I stole
a few tragic Maybe violence wasn't the answer I can't
believe violence was not the answer I'm gonna send his or
her ex-boyfriend to this hero training All right Investigate
the reports and we'll send you to I'll leave that oh sure oh
yeah no like it had no one no one has that so happily gave
up water boy are you oh thank god um yes i gave up water boy
for depression man because i will be happy to assist in
transport if someone wished to fly over because i can send
him to his ex's uh to his ex's lesson to make it even more
awkward.
Like, you don't get to do that with Waterboy.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, what I've learned is that we have to stop putting it
on combat.
What?
Oh, hey, look.
This is what I learned today.
Oh, is he already maxed out?
Unlucky.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you?
No.
No, don't do this to me.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, thank God we fucking made it.
See, you don't need fire.
All we get to do, we can just punch people.
That's fine.
All right.
We'll have him learn something.
We might as well.
We don't have anything else to do.
How are you depressed?
We got a job well done.
How is your depression?
Have you just not been...
Have you thought about not being sad?
I'm a bad person Just Alright Twice was set to max And
removes rest time after Stats dropped to one Wait that's
good that means less combat And reduce call completion If
after it fails a third he is down Yeah that's fine There's
no way he's gonna fail again Easy don't be sad
Alright Everything is fine Oh, I didn't get the bonus.
Oh, I did get the bonus.
Yay.
I'm sure we don't work on commission.
We did it.
I said my chemistry, people.
Oh, sonar require.
Engage in a diplomatic relations.
Win them over with...
Diplomatic has to be with, like, your brain, right?
And I maxed that out.
Oh, thank God.
I was gonna say, thank God.
I better max it out.
Yay!
We're friends with the MUD people!
Let's go!
See?
MUD people, MUD people.
Alright, let's have more smart people in our team.
Let's have more combat.
Guys, what do we put in more combat?
Do you think I'll be a bad idea?
Yeah!
We're friends!
We're friends now!
i already have my max career so it doesn't really matter how
many i failed now like i can't get like super promoted
because i you guys won't let me the boss i could have had a
i could have been promoted and a raise if you guys let me
fuck my boss
then why didn't you because we had a democratic vote and i
ain't a corrupted leader yet you know it feels like for the
first time for that day i felt i felt kind today which i'm
sure you would appreciate been nice that we get to spend
more time together right the team's more important team
might fuck up for a while the people's choice they're gonna
get good that day i felt exceptionally bad than i ever could
alone
but just when i feel like i got a handle on it got it
figured out i think about chase and my dad and shroud then i
get all fucked up You know what I'm saying, beef?
You know what I mean.
He's my emotional support animal.
Ha ha ha!
Yeah, exactly.
See, this is why I appreciate her talks.
Oh?
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, hi.
What are you doing here?
I'm decent.
Definitely a house that needs some warmth.
Wait.
I'm in my underwear.
I am in my underwear.
What are you doing here?
I can see you.
I was joking when I asked if you're decent.
I know.
I just need you to know that I know how I look right now.
All right.
That rubs out, by the way.
You just have to put a little muscle into it.
Do you know the way you want to hang this?
You could have just knocked on my door.
I think he's only considered where he'd hang himself.
That corner seems fine.
Whoa, what the fuck?
It's a housewarming gift for your housewarming party,
brother.
I told people to bring a lamp or something.
Wait, wait.
People.
This is gonna be a party now?
Look, I'm not really...
My home's depressing.
Not what it looks like to me, but you're tidy whities.
Oh!
This is your family photo area?
Kind of morbid.
Which I'm kind of...
At least I had a family.
I'll go this too far.
We figured it out, brother.
The man can be Mecca again.
Oh?
After your little premature Jack explosion, I had this
feeling like I'd seen it before.
Then Vizzi asked me to get the...
energy reading we got this morning and cross-reference with
recent calls wait wait wait wait it's not destroyed wait
what and a bunch of b-grade villains have been trying to
unlock its power only to end up blowing their asses off like
you did then they sell it on the next sucker and the same
shit oh so there's a four times that we've tracked how does
shroud not know this yeah probably think like us i think it
was destroyed how the fuck do people small fuck oh yeah i
was gonna say surely he's like deeper in the villain which
is why we're having a party the society know every low-level
super villain in three counties that's true we track its
location they'll know who has it then we kick in some doors
knock some heads snatch that ship back and you'll be pulsing
no time regardless of how this plays out yeah i feel like it
could be a trap too because i feel like why is that so easy
i can't remember the last time someone did something so whoa
what is wrong with you just get gushy after we find the soul
I'm just trying to be nice.
I got with my boat over here in Marina Dore, which is...
Oh, Yari territory.
Why, she's here first.
You know much about those guys?
Uh, all money crew of Ascot wearing coke heads.
Skylaw, Arcadia runs it now.
Three generations that family's been trying to think of me.
Huh?
What are they accusing you of?
You're cute.
We're gonna ask you some questions about a piece of peck
they moved.
But first, Rob gotta put on pants.
Aw, what?
But then I can't do this.
Yep, right on that.
Damn!
Harassment from my co-workers Oh yeah, Sound Guy Has
everything been okay so far for Sound?
I don't know you said anything earlier Oh, putting on my
pants Nice I know, I can't I can't hook up with her Why did
they give me two choices?
Oh hey Moist owner
oh hey depression man he gave me a lamp as well oh pizza
pizza party pizza time
okay i could try and hook up with sonar and to end her as
well.
I don't think he has to be monogamous.
I make the choices for him.
Lamps for everyone.
Oh my god, get a table?
That's fine.
This was already gonna get striked.
I'm fine with that.
Patience.
Oh, he's fine with her ex now.
With his ex.
Oh, no.
Oh, he's hugging me.
That's like sex for him on his planet.
Oh, he saved his...
He shaved his depression.
Oh, he's not depressed anymore.
Oh, my God.
No, she is dating him.
God, Morsona has everything.
Rich, handsome, in the hunger games, and also hooking up
with a devil lady.
God!
And he's a bat!
I'm so happy.
That's why he's the goat.
You do understand how projectors work, right?
dramatic and bare walls are a sign of depression why is it
always a warehouse by the docks it's where stuff comes in
and stuff goes out it's that easy not a rocket scientist are
you no oh yeah where is flabby yes you're in security didn't
come to my party that's where it gets tricky oh why didn't
he come to my party oh that's more than you need a army i'll
go can't shoot what you can't see look this is really great
work But doing this tonight is out of the question.
Hitting a secure location like this is something they would
handle downtown.
Are you kidding?
There's enough firepower in this room to take down a fucking
Kaiju.
A bunch of drunk ass Z-teamers, please.
Y'all wouldn't make it past the front door.
No one's asking you to do a goddamn thing, okay?
Hey, no need for that.
When we have to be stealthy with all the cameras?
We'll get the warehouse tomorrow night.
Tomorrow night?
This thing's not gonna sit still for that long.
Make a plan first.
This is incredible, Viz.
But Blazer's right.
We make a plan.
rush this yeah i feel like i feel like it's a trap that we
go in now you understand that word or is it got too many
syllables for you why don't you go walk your ass around a
mall grandpa heroes are talking you are no hero whoa whoa
chase you named yourself invisible bitch and you had it
fucking right chase you're drunk you need to stop talking
you want to get people hurt get people fucking kill back off
that's my girlfriend chase that's enough i defend my queen
even though i don't i didn't i wasn't on her side of him
robert doesn't need to keep going out there with no powers
putting his life on the line to make up for assholes like
you he doesn't need to be mecca man to be a hero chase
please that's right i fight for my girl wait robert's mecca
man what you're playing them you're playing yourself you
know i'm robbing invisible but i fucking see I'm Robin.
Oh, no, you don't know anything about me.
I know you're a liar criminal.
I know you're fucking dangerous.
What else do we I'm Robin?
Wait, wait a minute.
He dogs me wait wait chase Wait Oh my god Guys, I'm Robin
guys That bitch sent his ass airborne.
How are you not dead?
You okay?
Are you all right?
That's enough for tonight So shots I'm sorry this turned
into I got dots Anyone who utters one word about what
happened tonight fucking answers to me Got it?
Oh, no, is this flat big?
Oh shit.
Oh, that's awkward I'm guys guys, frogs From that thing, you
know, oh, that's it's okay.
I think he wasn't here, right?
I think he wasn't here.
It's okay.
What's up?
That's a red zone.
Sir, you can't park there.
Is that funny?
Did I make a funny joke?
Came back to apologize.
All these goddamn apartments look the same.
That guy watching us from the balcony walked into his house
thinking it was yours.
about that fuck you yeah he said he was sorry well fuck you
too okay let's just oh that's a crystal is that shug night
you sure this ain't vodka she told you made quite a first
impression didn't know you would end up spitting in people's
mouths kinky is that internet somehow made sense so bad for
dog you sound how you look another thing i can't do anymore
fuck maybe it's why i say the word so much uh sorry chase i
hadn't thought about that i had a pretty good run you ever
think about why we do what we do yeah i don't think i'm
stopping my dog in his time soon put it all on the line for
someone who won't ever know your name won't send you just
how i'm wired bedside when you get hurt no no no just how
i'm wired i guess and here you trying to rewire a bunch of
criminals yeah what's wrong with that everyone deserves a
second chance busy I was gonna walk off the team you know
she's feeling low talking about how she was born with powers
that always meant she'd end up as a villain like he was
faded I can see fix her so obviously gave her the pep talk
you know like that's all bullshit you make up your fate yada
yada i don't even remember what i said but i do remember
thinking oh the fuck yeah that must have been hard like if i
didn't have you you know my dad where would i have ended up
you were always good that was always in you is what makes us
different from a thief like her
What?
You racist motherfuckers.
Sorry,
I need to blow my nose.
Give me a sec.
I should have laughed at that.
Sorry.
Whoa, whoa there.
Whoa.
I didn't mean that in a racist way, bro.
I meant like, you know, You know, you know, because you're
young and you do reckless things.
I, bro, Mechaman situation is crazy, bro.
Racial profiling from Mechaman.
No, whoa.
Getting that Google Doc you ridden.
Oh, yeah, but that doesn't count.
That was for somebody else.
What, you quietly contemplating?
Yeah, I guess I hadn't considered some things.
But I think the answers are out there, if you just listen to
the wind.
I see why you and Beef get along.
Oh, where's my guy?
Oh, I'm sorry.
My poor boy.
That's it.
There's my boy.
There's my good boy.
Who's a good boy?
Beef is.
That's right.
Oh, oh, and Viz the bitch is heading there
Is there a mic on this?
Hey, hey, can you hear me?
The fuck are you doing?
Oh, not much just looking for your stupid-ass pulse It's
somewhere on this big-ass boat That's what she called
herself.
Is that not what she called herself?
You know who's not good beefy boy?
You know who's a real pain busy get out of there now look
Oh, what the dead name!
Oh, dead!
Sorry, I'm busy gal.
I thought she hated the busy gal.
The name.
She's like, it's so stupid and corny.
Something would be great.
Yeah, let's start with something.
Okay, it's okay, I'm not tired.
I could eat my steak a little bit.
My...
Or busy.
I mean, she's doing something badass.
Bitch is an aggro.
to be derogatory.
I'd be like, what's up, bitch?
I remember this.
Up, upright.
Wait, is that?
Up, upright, guys.
Remember that.
Out of range.
What does that mean?
Shit.
I need a password.
Up, up.
Oh.
Up, up, right.
There you go.
Wait, there's nothing here.
Hey, I'm getting a huge energy reading coming from the
captain's quarters.
know where that is see that tower the biggest one it's at
the top oh perfect so you want me to cross this active
battlefield look i didn't want you to do any of this i get
it okay jesus keep your eyes peeled for a visit it looks
like she might know something she said that shit they're on
to me oh hey there's a door to your left there's them in
there Where's the lock?
Oh, it's, um, what's your name?
Oh my, I forgot her name.
It's been so long since we last saw her.
Oh, wait, no, never mind.
We're timed out.
Almost got it.
Okay.
Wait, how did it...
Oh.
There you go.
I got the...
I got the charge!
Don't worry.
I got you, girl.
Oh, shit.
all right left left upright guys what was the password again
left left left upright there you go guys like guys i just
saw it but what's the password
oh it's the wings too big it's not here i like i was looking
at it i was like guys what was it
this fucking guy Oh, and it's a guide too.
Lead him towards that speaker tower.
I've got an idea.
Better be a good one.
Okay.
Follow me, Feather Dick.
I got something real cool to show you.
Alright, we gotta figure out how to get down there.
At the tower.
Do your thing.
Working on it.
I'm trying my best.
I don't know what I'm doing!
There you go.
Uh.
got to grab electricity down here oh what oh no okay all
right there you go that's your work right I saved it busy
cover your ears don't work oh my god we're so gonna hook up
later if I make you oh my god
Yeah, good night Fuck me.
How am I supposed to get around that look?
Hey, just worry about not dying.
I'll find you a way around
These years are bad see guys I told you investing cut
investing in combat was a good idea Not the time to keep
focus I am so focused Oh, oh Don't mind me, just pushing
through Guys, remember this They're mining me
Okay, we got one of them away
Okay, um Okay Oh god, guys, guys, what was the password?
I forgot, what's the password?
What's the password?
What's the passwords?
Left, left, left, right Okay, left, left, left, right There
you go.
Now the crane There you go I don't do well when I'm
panicking.
Oh, shit.
The captain's quarters should be right in front of you.
Watch this.
Tell us where the pulse is, invisible bitch, before we go
full Pompeii on your ass.
Full Pompeii on my ass?
What kind of threat is that?
You're going to give me diarrhea?
Wait, don't.
That was predictable.
What do we do when she's invisible?
That is such an overpowered...
That is overpowered.
powered it's in the safe the safe i don't know how to open a
fucking safe wait hard attack wait no all right what do you
mean hard attack but yeah okay guys hurry up come on oh oh i
was like come on guys hard attack
Never mind Never mind I spoke to suit It's just like Guys
come on really
There you go Alright shit there's no more Alright that's
fine I don't know what I did here Okay encryption key
collected Okay.
Wait, did he respawn?
Okay, there you go, it's fine.
We're fine.
Okay, now...
Okay, it was...
I was literally playing Pac-Bat.
You know what?
I guess it does.
Okay.
So now all you gotta do is sneak past the...
Why did it stop?
Wait, what?
Wait, you're right.
Shit, are they?
Oh, Shroud?
What's going on?
Our creator's time?
Just hang on.
Trying to get the camera back online.
Wait, is this Shroud?
You're good.
Just take one step at a time.
Just go invisible.
Oh, stop.
Oh, shit.
Why the fuck don't you just go invisible?
but he's right behind her isn't he hey busy stay calm your
inhaler it's just a few feet in front of you okay you gotta
get to it oh
that's why she always has trouble no hey busy he's just
gonna keep fucking with you but you don't give up okay oh
she can't go invisible with the power of the thing This is
like freezing.
Bro, she can't freeze.
You get up.
Get up.
Oh, no, he has to go.
Keep up.
No!
He's gonna die!
Chase!
Okay, yeah, you're good.
He's gonna have a heart attack.
Okay.
How much did he age?
Oh, no.
Do you have a heart attack?
Oh, why is anyone calling?
Why did I run out of self-calling 911?
What the fuck am I gonna do?
Oh, my God.
Ewan wanted to wait and make a plan.
Oh, yay, I'm the majority.
Ewan helped him.
Yay!
We did, we helped him.
Dan said, you and Forfer posed in the Mechaman.
We didn't really have a lot of hard choices.
We failed to deal with the delivery bots.
Yeah.
Yay!
friends with them yeah played as a bard yay let's try with
being a bard oh wait i am 9-1-1 oh you're right yay my most
said hero for better than 60 percent i forgot i am 9-1-1 how
what do i do when i'm 9-1-1 the week after this episode felt
so loud oh yeah you guys have to wait a week after because
they episode seven and eight a week after
that's why I waited you know all my friends they were like
you gotta play dispatch I was like oh wait I hate this is
why I hate episodic shit I fucking hate episodic content
because like there's like a cliffhanger and then you have to
remember what happened like in the last episode and
everything to like when you're especially if the episodes
take very long to release because that was basically the
Walking Dead the Walking Dead took so long to release in
between um episodes so it's like so like people have they
always have to have a recap and everything but um and then i
was like telling my friends i was like i'm gonna when is the
next i'm gonna wait until everything is done so i can just
play play play play and like in
collaboration with critical role is chase dead dead come on
chase you're not crying you're not dead right no you're not
i cry all the time is that chase really when when i was your
age i cried for weeks when the raiders left la classy chase
right totally the same as my dad never being home whoa yeah
language and it was the same my pops had season tickets
growing up seats sucked but i just like being there with
them so yeah when they moved i was crying like a little
bitch too This before he age.
Yes, bitch.
That's exactly what I'm saying.
What do you want from the store?
Your dad gave me a hundred and I gotta break the shit
anyway.
He pays you?
Yeah.
Fuck yeah, he pays me.
Now, come on.
What was this?
What was my dad's job?
I want a cigar!
I'm trying to go broke every time you get lonely.
Can I get a swisher thing?
The fuck you want with a swisher?
Isn't that what you and dad smoke?
Yeah.
Uh, yes.
That, that is what we smoke.
But don't share it with your dad.
But didn't my dad do it for free?
No, I thought my dad did it for free like me.
Or was he also a subscriber?
Yeah.
Oh, so he didn't do it for free?
I did.
Oh.
There, bitch.
You happy now?
Yay!
Smoking!
Don't smoke, guys.
That was my grandpa, not my dad.
That was part of the superhero team.
Yeah, teaching children how to smoke.
Your favorite.
I didn't realize you two were that close.
Teach him young.
Oh, he's alive.
He was like a brother.
He was like a big brother to me.
I didn't appreciate it enough.
I'm sorry.
Chase had only babysit nights when dad had to deal with
something big.
Working late, he called him.
I was fine being alone, but I'd still ask to have him wash
me because I could guilt trip him into buying me shut.
Duke, thank you, Mr. Richel, thank you, thank you, and happy
birthday.
We'll sing you a happy birthday soon, Duke, after, you know,
the guy, after, like, the dying guy is gone.
So maybe one less door run for bitch-ass Robert, and he
wouldn't be stuck in here.
That's what you're saying, right?
I mean, it was, but now that you put it like that.
Hey, the only person that put Chase here, investigation
invisible suspended obviously but i think you should
consider cutting her from the team no i'm not saying you
should i'm just saying you should consider it might make
things worse it's a hundred percent i'm keeping her i'm
using all my power to keep her in that might just make
things worse no that's my girlfriend it's just i can't help
but think that we've already cut a hero for far less yeah
but she didn't want to fuck me that's different yay nepotism
just gets better and better vending machine the true
whatever i want yeah see if i hooked up with the boss she
would have given me a hundred dollar allowance he told me
that Really?
He's proud of me?
Instead of just $5, I could have got $100.
Oh, I'm sorry, Chase.
Robert.
Twinkie money.
It's not about the money, Thurkey.
It's about power and promotion.
Oh.
Got Twinkie, though.
oh she gave me a shitty dot five dollar not even flat she
made me crumpled up my five dollars water boy i just
realized it's what's his name the youtube the guy who does
like um those types of animations where i'm just where you
like trace over do we where you use like live action footage
yeah Joel Haver.
I love that guy.
I love his animation.
He was also in Smiling Friends, but the fuck you save him.
But like he, his animations on YouTube is so good.
Yeah, rotoscoping.
He used roto.
He used like, not specific.
Yeah, he used like rotoscoping animation mixed with like,
what was it like, the new AI feature in the Photoshop?
I'm a little mad too.
fair and visigal was the one who and then chase shouldn't
have oh do you think he did the right thing i mean i don't
it seems very not clear or unclear i think he did i think
chase knew he was the only one who could save her and he
knew the risk so yeah i think it was ultimately the right
thing he died for a villain so that means she's redeemable
yeah twinkie oh case in point whoa
feel better kind of i'll clean it up what the fuck like that
did she have a crush on chase or something like what kind of
reaction was that hey hey water boy is the leaper build
version of what happened uh let's get to it main takeaways
are that invisigal has been suspended so we're a person down
the shift and that chase is in the infirmary and he's in
pretty rough shape
no he's depressed again just don't tell him i told you that
oh i've found doing something good always helps when i'm
feeling bad we're fortunate to have that opportunity
something chase never took for granted so let's get to work
my gosh there's like no off days here i guess you don't
really have an off day when you're you when everyone's
always calling 9-1-1 I mean, what do you do when like you're
calling 9-1-1 and you're like, sorry, we're on a holiday?
Like, what the fuck do you do?
Also, Duke, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Duke.
Yay!
Happy birthday.
Also, Cap and Romeo, they give the super chat thank you.
Thank you.
Sleep with the boss and you get the executive key for free
items.
Exactly.
yeah i guess you just die like like you have an emergency
during new years and we're like sorry we all could really
use some help getting them back it doesn't move them as fast
okay we'll send depression man two depression men
don't worry prism is slowly walking over there thanks to the
structural reinforcement the damage to the resort is not as
bad as it could evacuate there is identify the structural
integrity
favorite okay oh depression and jack are best friends oh my
god could send them together i didn't realize oh golem has
no friends it's all right oh wait oh my golem's friends with
invisigal busy i should send these two together more um i
make a sense that oh i can't i keep sending the other two up
chuck's rugby team lost and he's throwing a very toxic uh
acid is ancillary vomit is using the rain to rain terror,
use necessary force.
Oh, necessary force.
Huh?
Oh, sure.
Wait, why?
Why don't you want to do that?
What?
Do you hate me?
Oh, yeah, I'm sure.
Why don't you want to do this?
I feel like I have to use punch up and... Wait, why is he
depressed?
Are you sad if she's gone?
Fucking useless.
No, you come in.
I tell you, this is your job.
I mean, yeah, I think so.
We're going to do these two.
Oh, shite.
I know this guy.
I used to have more hair.
Bro, this is your job.
She's going to come back.
Identify the structural.
I'll send them these two.
Put the synergy up.
Oh, they're all busy now.
Volt of Virtue cars to short out.
It's just hacking.
It's fine.
Man.
Why are you all sad?
I don't...
Oh.
Is this...
Oh, it does.
It zaps it for me.
That's good.
Just stop being sad, guys.
Okay.
Alright.
We got him zapped.
Um, remember this.
Left, right, right, left, right, right, left.
Okay, remember this, guys.
Left, right, right, left.
Yeah, I need him to be let here.
Zap.
There you go.
Whoa, whoa!
Okay!
How did he get closer to me?
That's crazy.
I was like, bro, you're supposed to, like, kill him, not
bring him closer.
Okay.
Bad touch.
Whoa, buddy.
Back away.
Be no good yet living on the edge.
But, you know, you know.
Oh, what's that?
I know this guy.
Wait, wait, man.
Can you go talk to him?
Yeah.
Bro, the antivirus.
Who if you ever got around to adopting that dog?
Nice.
He knows him, buddy.
All right.
them you had to make more friends oh yeah no we didn't
overkill on that
all right nice now everyone's just resting i know we need to
see these there okay this should be fine right oh shit yeah
it should be fine yeah let's go oh level up did i see did
someone said More combat.
See, look, guys.
I restrained myself from more combat.
Golem.
Golem, what are you doing?
Golem, what?
Oh, Golem's shit face.
I think he's about to piss mud on the high school.
Oh, no.
He's super drugged.
Don't worry.
I can heal you.
I didn't think that was weird.
Come on, buddy.
There you go.
You're better now.
Guys, I gave him a bandaid.
I want to get shit faced right now more than anything, but
we've got to do it.
put a band-aid over his mouth just hang in there until the
end of the shift after that you can do whatever the fuck you
want cool cool can someone please go get golem before he
does more property damage all right we did it oh no save
golem from the carrying him back clean be angry whose cars
okay here we'll do you too does that require intelligence
calming people down chat i just want better friends maybe i
mean i could you know i'll send him too because i need more
intelligent people i not really okay i'm just gonna send all
three of them in so that i can just because i need them to
not be a we have too many with too many unga bunga teammates
right now who controls bugs apparently they have beef with
one of our farmers using pesticides it's getting real
biblical down here take down the bug controlling save the
farmer from being attacked.
Let me do this.
I cannot do that.
Um, we'll just wait a little bit.
We'll just...
I realize I can't just do that.
Um, oh, oh, this is interesting.
Um, she's more intelligent.
Uh, we'll do...
I don't know.
Do we need combat for this or...
No, Flambay.
No, Flambay is too strong.
Oh, wait, no, he's fine.
This has to be...
Do we need...
It's speed?
Okay, we'll do this.
It's fine.
See?
This is...
This is 10, right?
Yeah, he's fine.
There you go.
Flambay, go in there.
Flang's a bitch.
You can't see shit.
That's gonna save...
Let me keep fly in the rain.
God damn, slip and slide.
I fucking love slipping.
Yay!
Golem's okay now.
And they're better friends.
I like it.
He's sober.
That's how you fix sobriety.
We'll do mobility.
We'll make you fast as fuck, boy.
Wee!
Where he finishes.
He heals up so fast.
Alright.
I don't know what the percentage is for this.
Yay!
We did it!
Nice.
We've arrested a bug lady.
Is she, like, hot, though?
Like, the one-punched man, little lady?
The Bone Zone pissed off the wrong gang, and they're holding
him hostage.
In the Bone Zone?
Listen, I know he sucks, but he writes my checks.
Can you please just rescue him?
There you go.
We got you.
Are they all really...
Are they... Okay, level two.
Okay, level two, and...
I'm gonna try raising up Prism and Flamb and Depression
Man.
and Jacksepticeye.
Hi.
Just going to confirm one of your Z-Team heroes for our
interview this afternoon to discuss the Phoenix program.
Oh, okay.
Well, you're Sonar.
He's gonna have public speaking.
What's this?
I'll bet Golem in there.
I really think it can help the team too.
Another one?
Terrence?
Let's learn.
Oh!
Okay, we can.
Oh, shit.
We can't.
Um, I gotta send Sonar in here first.
Um...
yeah i think ah i want to i'll i want to send him in but the
thing is i need him to do this first hello so i'll do that
later working i'm running late at the airport i zoned out
there for a skirt the mayor's assistant to look for the
flight okay that has to be mobility i have that in here it's
fine wait let's do this first all right what did you get
expanse the fill each increasing stats by up to 200%.
Oh!
Now we can do this.
We'll do this.
I like that.
We don't need to... Yeah, I think he can... Yeah, one seems
really, really strong in general.
Alright, what's this?
Oh yeah, I don't know.
Fucking ace that shit.
Prism's power up is so strong.
Like, I love the double up.
Expand the red rings coordinate strikes across torrents.
Oh, talk up the reform finally his degree is worth it now
stick to the talking points finally i'm literally a
professional bullshitter and that's how it's fucking done i
knew his degree okay if i miss that flight i'm fucking toast
red rings corning strike cross looks like they are okay but
which one's this go all out bring them a fight and make them
pay for what they did to chase don't get hurt okay we'll do
that uh escort the mayor's assistant to the airport before
the flight wait who should I want to fight them so I need
guys who do we put for this running late golem solo okay
we'll do golem solo then golem for this solo what do we do
flambe we put flambe here is it speed and defense
do that.
Alright.
And then flight license.
Yeah, we don't have anybody.
Okay, we're gonna have to play it safe.
We need to play it safe.
No, we're going all in.
I'm sending oh shit.
Oh, I know what to do.
Get in!
Oh, wait.
Returning.
Okay, wait for her to return.
And then I know what to do.
Alright, coffee time.
You coming back.
Alright, depression!
Vote depression, man!
And then there's no way.
I swear to God, if we fuck up with I swear to God, if it's
intellect that we are missing, the one point of
intelligence, I swear to fucking God.
Like, there's no way I can fail this.
Oh, nice.
Oh, it was just me.
Like, the one person.
There we go.
If he dies, he'll be taken care of.
Yeah, that's nice to know.
More mobility.
I don't think...
Girl, what the fuck even are you?
Alright.
Oh?
This fucking rain is flooding our neighborhood.
We need this water gone.
Move quickly before the flooding.
Let's say what could cost...
Oh, we need speed.
Fuck.
Um...
We'll put another in speed.
But we need speed, though.
Like, do we want...
Which one do we want, guys?
Is it an all-arounder?
Do we want intelligence or charisma?
Or, like, all-arounder?
Brain?
Middle?
Solo, golem, and center.
Okay, got it.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my god.
finn okay i can send sonar to learn how to fly all right
learn how to fly yeah nice there's no way i swear to god i
swear to god in my food i can oh my god water boy's not even
in the team okay what do you mean water boy he's just a
janitor okay do we fetch what does fetch the bucket or
examine the storm drain for clogs it's i mean we're all
around here i feel like it doesn't matter which one i do bro
he's just he's not even this oh that for mine
yeah no sorry i guess some people died man we said less
water not more Okay, rescue civilians.
Navigate.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, man.
How the hell is I supposed to know it's 10 speed?
Okay, yeah, thank God.
I was gonna say I swear to God, but I'm gonna 1%
intelligence.
Wait, you're depressed?
But you made a friend.
Wait, what was the entire...
Okay.
How are you depressed?
You have a friend!
You're leveled up!
We need backup down here.
There's a mass pile up in the tanker caught fire.
The fire is growing.
Okay, Flamb.
We'll use fire to put out fire.
That's how it works, right?
He learns how to fly now, right?
So when our flies to cause, we're greatly reducing, and also
carries not...
Oh, shit, nice.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Flamb.
Flamb is my fastest character.
Oh, my god.
Oh.
I can't send him in.
What are you talking about?
I'm trying to think right now.
Okay, because I can only send one of them in.
I didn't send Flamb here.
or there's no nobody's gonna come back in time I think I
have to send I'm sending Flamb to fight fire for fire yeah
I'm sending him he's gonna we're gonna fight fire with fire
let's go
there's nothing else I could do she's the only one here um
yeah it's fine the room's booked yeah Confirmed it this
morning.
We're all good.
That's how it works.
I want to see you all now.
Someone's going to fuck up.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Okay, apparently the fire versus... Okay, fire versus fire
strap was not it.
Who would have done?
Pray to RNG.
Oh my god, what is this?
What the fuck is this RNG?
All right, so several people have died today.
It's okay.
They just didn't, they missed their subscription yet.
Let's just say they missed their subscription.
Okay, team.
Good shift, all things considered.
See you tomorrow.
Hopefully with some good news.
Okay.
Hey, Twinkies.
Aw, don't worry.
Michael's steak.
Finished it all.
Okay.
Only 50 people dead today.
Guys, I lowered my record.
My lowest yet.
Wait, why are you guys fighting?
your personal best
you've got a little oh cheers lad good looking out just
paying for this okay who's gonna pay for this I'll pay I'm
the one that caused the damage with what oh oh okay cool now
that we got all of the details clear Aww.
Why?
That's just a difference of opinion.
I got heated, got in Golem's face.
He had every right to punt me through the wall.
Right.
It's a door and I got you were actually in his face.
More like ankle, which made him easier to kick.
What the fuck is going on?
We want her out.
What?
We basically took a board vote.
That's why we're in the board.
Why you're voting in these out?
I'm neither human nor reformed villain.
Nor particularly interested in this conversation.
What did she do?
I only came in as I thought we were playing Magic the
Gathering tonight.
I am hoping we still may.
Who wants you to stay?
Just me.
Aww.
But the team is more important than any one of us, so I
won't stand in the way.
You could have led with that.
We heard about the suspension bullshit.
It ain't enough, Robert.
Not for what she did.
to put everything we've been building at risk and for what
for me i like the bitch but she gotta go and by go we mean
cut just like you cut coop no one here wants to say i'm
gonna defend her but that's what it is i'm defending her i
don't care look i probably don't say this she did it for me
but i'm we're a family and i'm here soon A few months ago,
you wouldn't have been already committed in the needs of the
Z team.
And if you did, if I can't have muscle mommy, I'll have her
Soon But I'm not cutting this ago We don't kick people when
they're down.
We lift them up and I believe of her what I believe of all
of you That her heart is in the right place It's what took
us from being a team to being this weird fucked up family
look you're hurting okay I get it I'm hurting we are all
hurting good speech Robert better speech than what the
speech I was gonna do it's the time to come together and
heal oh
moral has dropped what do you me that was a good ass speech
what the fuck do you mean moral has dropped ohana means
family dizzy sorry i can come back why first time we met you
were in your underwear fitting right last time you see me
that i'd be in mine oh i really do appreciate you defending
me but you shouldn't i care about you they don't want me
here i care about you Courtney whoa no you went in knowing
the risks but you were willing to put on the line I care
about you girl me yeah she went she did all that for me yes
so I'm willing to put myself on the line and he's not the
only one so please don't throw all that away by walking away
from this first name that's for you lose Fuck, from me.
They're right.
I don't deserve anyone's forgiveness.
Anyone's help, anyone's love.
I love you, though.
Because I can never repay it.
Nothing I do will ever make up for what I've already done to
you.
I don't need you to repay it.
I hope getting the Astral Pulse back would help, but I
couldn't even do that.
Vizzy, you don't owe anyone anything, okay?
Least of all me.
Was there that night What are you saying?
Oh I said my own thing but my asthma was getting worse and
they had an augment that could increase my life Bro what you
play Xbox to work for them paying down for years
You two please
But she also plays Xbox.
She was part of the game?
It is from this where she decided that being bad is bad.
I have to hold that cleared if I was able to do one thing.
She didn't do it.
There's a bomb on the back of my command undetected.
Wait, she's the one that puts a bomb?
Good news, buddy.
Trout says he just wants the Astral Pole.
Which we all know.
Isn't really yours anyway.
Oh, it was never about me.
So, all the red...
So, they all knew about her.
Oh, and then she saw me and she's like, wait, he's cute.
I can't kill him.
I know.
She let her...
Okay, guys, okay.
I'll see.
She let her pussy talk.
I quit the moment I placed it Do you keep I walked out
before it even blew
My augments conveniently stopped working Oh So I signed up
for the Phoenix program the next day Wait how did it?
Oh cause she didn't kill her Give me the chance to fuck your
life up twice I forgive you Well I forgive you So there, we
fucking chill out now.
Tokyo is so degenerate.
You fucking forgive me?
You haven't even like processed what's going on.
You did villain shit while you were a villain.
Does it change things that you dropped without me?
I forgive you though.
That's in the past.
You're not the same person that was there that night.
Neither am I.
That's sweet, but...
I feel numb.
Hey, stop making this feel like a goodbye.
you're suspended it's temporary i'm not letting anyone cut
you all i wanted from this was for you to look at me the
same way you look at blazer if it was just once you know
that i don't look at blazer i don't know what you mean by
that yes you do i chose sorry my chat chose you over blazer
so come on girl what the fuck do you mean Oh, like a hero.
Oh, sorry.
I thought you meant something.
Oh, whoa.
Oh,
like a hero.
Lean in.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Everywhere.
Why the fuck would I lean out?
This was all I fucking put my career on the line.
I put my career on the line to keep her on the team.
I might as well lean in.
This was what I was building for.
Here's don't worry, the censorship will save me.
Alright, boy.
You boys don't stay up too late.
HR violation.
Let's go.
Face the U.S.
Super chat that you thank you.
I saw a story on SDN Hero.
Got hurt last night.
Can't tell them it was track start.
I want people to know what Chase did, but I don't know how
he'd feel.
or should i say it was invisible they messed up when we got
to her so it wouldn't be alive
invisible i just feel like oh my gosh she types types like
in wait why track start okay is it track start because it
would be a better ending because my first thought was
invisible chase is the hero yeah but like but i feel like if
we do if we're busy, then, uh, you dox you, you dox it.
But I can sip all the way.
Okay, we'll do, we'll do track start.
Dox for a dox, exactly.
You know the same way, thank you.
Doc's maxing.
I mean, I hope they all die.
I'm serious.
Any dumbass walking into a trap that fucking stupid should
have the plug pulled right now.
Just pillows over faces.
Oh man, have you seen what the poison does to their faces?
They get all red and puffy and...
Oh.
Oh, that's me.
I'm back at the villain bar.
I'm sorry.
It's my fault.
I've been distracting you.
Give me another drink.
I smashed mine.
Sure.
You all right?
You seem perturbed.
Ah, fuck.
I know what's going on.
Kid probably lost someone there.
That's why he's been staring at that shit all night.
a drink on me yeah wait is that shroud he looks too normal
nah this one's on me shroud that's you why are he at the
villain bar
it has to be shroud like he looks way too normal to be in a
villain bar and he looks like a goddamn nerd
oh oh my Yeah, he looks like a villain.
Yeah, I'm like, you have to be a villain to be at a villain
bar.
And like, he looks way too normal.
And he looks like a fucking nerd.
Only Shroud is a nerd.
Get fucked.
What?
Cheers, fellas.
To the fucking dream.
It's like everyone else in this bar is like, mech it up.
And then there's this fucking guy with glasses.
This nerd.
and he's all too what's up you don't like asses let it go I
gotta get close to I gotta get close to Shroud right real
quick I have to let it go so if I put too much of a if I too
much put too much commotion then he's gonna get away okay
now I don't know what he's talking about Dreckles you mind
telling me what's going on oh shit I
respect her Blazer Real fucking superhero Oh I know we're in
a villain bar but have some class You know
If you're gonna blow some fucker's brains out Non-slip mats
are a must Need some for the hideout Feel silly calling you
to hide out
Can you take care of them for me?
Obviously you two don't need an introduction With pleasure.
Oh, shit, he knows!
Troud!
I fucking knew, Allison!
Why is this nerd in the village bar?
It has to be Troud.
This old-ass nerd.
I fucking knew it.
There's no solving human nature.
I damn knew that was him.
Fucking nerd-ass.
All you can do...
he's controlled it oh I believe him boss if he had something
to say he would have said it by now I thought you wanted
revenge this was your father's gun kept it in his locker
fully loaded six shots he couldn't have predicted I'd use it
to kill him The first bullet grazed his shoulder.
I hadn't adjusted to the adrenaline spike.
Wait, is that fired Sonar?
Would he join Trout?
Bro, what?
He's lying on the floor or I was full of fear when I put the
floor through his face.
A bit of a waste to put the fifth through that idiot's
skull, but I wanted to make sure it worked after all these
years.
What the fuck is Sonar gonna do?
Talk me to death?
Your father was the last person to touch this bullet.
And now...
Oh.
16 and a half percent chance it touches you next your
invisible girlfriend stole my astral pulse to give it to you
where the fuck is it i don't she's still heroes i'm gonna
i'm gonna spit in his face i'll control this i'm gonna kill
you that's cute that's right do it this is why i hate luck I
won the gotcha.
If I had it wide, I let you stream me about a fucking
pinata.
She didn't get the pulse.
I won the gotcha.
Yay.
I trusted my gotcha a lot.
You actually believe that.
You show him.
What?
Invisibitch has the pulse that I know.
How?
What I don't know.
is why she didn't give it to you she played you too here I
am thinking she's working with you but she's fucking with
you both she didn't take it for you she took it for herself
no she did to protect me no I don't trust you she fooled me
too no she did it to protect me i love his strength oh
that's my girl what's this oh blazer dad see that it says
dad on the top the blonde blazer i fired the bartender but i
can still get you something to drink no thank you into what
do i owe the pleasure I'm here for him
In five minutes this bar will be surrounded By SDN agents,
heroes, and whoever else you in your ring have pissed off
recently Which happens to be every gang in Los Angeles Now
if Okay mom She's fucking bluffing What
Sorry about that If they weren't shit you wouldn't have cut
them Oh Why is he giving her a tip off?
Why is she giving her a tip?
I can see I'm unnumbered.
That eventually I would fall.
But by my read...
I'm taking a lot of you with me.
Oh!
So all of you can leave now.
Or half of you can die here.
Orify me.
That's a fucking superhero.
Chills.
Top-notch.
You made them nervous.
Okay, we're out of here.
Take your piss-soaked pants out the back, please.
Don't want to tempt this tiger.
Now's not our time, Blazer.
But it's coming sooner than you think.
Oh.
And by my calculations, it was closer to 32%.
But half sounds better.
Yeah, she rounded up, guys.
Guys, look.
There's no...
There's...
Wait, can't believe you found...
I don't know how she found me first.
I don't see how to find me.
Yeah.
I tracked your phone.
Sorry.
I'll never forgive you.
Jesus, Saki.
Oh.
Don't worry.
Okay.
HR?
I know.
Ring, ring, ring.
I got another write-up for you.
Another citation.
She got you pretty bad.
Are you sure he's right about him?
Phenomenal.
I saw the footage.
What is her play?
Why wouldn't she tell you if she hasn't?
Oh, okay.
First of all, why are you tracking me?
I don't understand what she would want it for.
I trust her.
I trust her!
She's protecting me!
What matters is I trust her.
I think you're more optimistic.
I think they fired HR.
You're probably right.
Just need to sit here for like a few weeks, then I'll be
right as rain.
Take your time.
you're conscious see when the pain's constant yeah but she
cuts the first thing that went was h.i used to that goes for
physical and emotional really is nice up here thank you
don't remember if i've thanked you before but about 50 times
you were muttering it the whole flight then i take it back
you should know i was going to take you to the actual
hollywood song oh wait can i kiss her too oh
have you heard about polygamy miss blazer
wait what what the is going on agreed
wait what oh shit why the helicopter What the fuck?
Oh.
Okay, to be fair, 50% of them are SDN subscribers.
So we only have to stay 50% of the town.
Bro, that guy's a flasher.
You're not leaving me here again.
Do we not have a superhero that can, like, heal?
Like, is that not...
That power not exist in this fucking world?
GG's no support.
Honestly, I'm like, GG's no support.
Yeah.
Yay.
Nice.
We're all sims.
Forgive her.
Yay.
We're all thinking of our peepees.
Yippee.
Yay.
thoughts win again yeah you at 10% chose a cigar yeah damn
right the real majority okay 46% didn't assault the barn
yippee we all smoky
okay rescue golem chose to go out yeah we all chose to beat
up the red ring Phenomenon, you perform better than 20%.
Because he's phenomenal.
No, I've never smoked in my life.
My dad smoked.
In Asia, pot smoking is, like, a norm.
Like, you could, in back then, you can, I think, I don't
know, you can still can, but, like, you could smoke in
restaurants.
Like, they have, like, each table will have a smoking tray.
man but now i think everyone just vapes now i think vaping
is a lot more dangerous can you can make it taste like
cotton candy
oh nice he's making him bellies his name's mr whiskey
yeah i'm very sure like vaping is a lot worse
oh hello oh Oh, yay!
He saved it.
Thank you.
That's, uh, you're a lifesaver.
Did he not go home?
I don't think he went home.
I think he went straight to work, bro.
What?
Nine to five.
A report coming in from the refinery.
Multiple augmented villains breaking containment.
Dispatch all available heroes in the area.
Boss, we don't have any heroes in the area.
What?
Can you handle things here?
Where are our heroes?
I just think I need to get out.
into the field for us to have a shot wait oh my god go we
got you gobert we got you oh shit the tablet keep an eye on
the feed stay don't save anyone i i was tempted to pick say
just to say just be like don't save people stay here i was
this close honestly oh he's still not back the best.
Stay.
Let them die.
We can use whatever you can give.
Yeah, what?
There's only three?
What happened?
What you mean is this it?
Bitch, you know what time it is.
Sorry.
I didn't mean it like that.
Thanks for getting out of bed or whatever you were up to.
Yeah, I'd say come here to fall asleep, so I might be just a
little.
Are you gonna finish your sentence, big man?
Huh?
No.
Oh, no.
He's fucking out of it.
Look, we're shorthand.
Technically for a prison.
We should have the rest of the team trickling in, so we'll
have to make do for now.
Lucky for us, we got the best three heroes on the roster.
We all know you'd say the same shit about whoever was here.
If we all know, then there's no reason to point it out.
Look alive.
Also, like, doesn't prison have concerts to do?
Like, I thought being a pop star makes you, like, extra
busy.
Like, I feel, oh, wait, what happens?
Oh, I guess there's...
Oh, whoa, oh!
Jesus!
city first things first yes half the team is missing let's
fix that immediately next la is on fire okay we'll work on
that third thing okay but when is la not on fire out of
every crack in the city damn that's a lot of things it is a
lot of things but nothing we can't handle so i need you guys
to focus shits only get and get worse if you don't you with
me i mean true but was there a force
Clear Red Ring grooms Protected Defenseless Employees.
Okay, um...
Red Ring just released an experiment from containment.
It's a, uh, big thing.
Oh, we'll just do.
We are crushing it, baby.
What do we want?
Wait, I should look at the other ones, too.
This year, but also last year and also the year before that.
And also...
Isn't that what we pay SDN for?
We're not evacuating.
Okay, you can...
Okay, yeah, we need to evacuate so you...
All right, so I'll put you...
Should he be on?
Middle?
Okay, middle.
All right.
Fucking rocks.
You go solo this.
Um, we're gonna try and figure out...
Doppel's out there already, but...
Determine whether the package is a threat and dispose...
Uh...
Shit.
Okay, dispose of the...
Determine whether...
Okay, you're not that smart, so...
I don't know.
Oh, I'm going to put you on this.
There's a suspicious package outside of City Hall.
Please send someone to investigate.
Bomb squad is tied up.
Yeah, this is intelligence.
But she's not that smart.
She's not that smart.
She's my second smartest, which isn't saying much, guys.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, her morale is down because I was like, no.
oh shit oh shit oh no we're not gonna evacuate that bar on
the top left that's torrents or what's left of it oh shit
all right it's okay that mayor mr yow he's not getting
re-elected all right everyone you should get live updates on
the state of the city let's kick some red ring it's fine
that means that mayor is gonna get impeached guys that's
okay Oh my god.
Oh, home.
Are you fucking getting me?
There's no time for this.
Okay, don't worry.
You're better now.
All right, this is fine.
All right, at least that one works.
Yoling.
Because the mayor was like, we're not evacuating.
Even though half the city was burning.
So that's on him.
These golems guys.
got me thank God um combat no combat no combat I can't keep
doing combat okay I have to send I'm just gonna send two I
think it's sent two here all right we gotta be successful
trying to step to me wait someone's tracker is freaking out
we'll do that hacking thing that you do all right hacking
time uh hi oh shit okay all right this is gonna be scary
because it's a high hack I've never done a high one before
oh fuck off are you kidding me
oh my god
yeah I need him to be here all right
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
That's right.
I got you now.
Zap, zap, bitch.
All right.
Come on.
Wait, that was high?
Oh, okay, yeah.
No, that makes sense.
Never mind.
Out of range.
I was like, bro, why the fuck was that one high?
No, I get it.
Does it not go anywhere?
Oh, it's right side.
Okay.
that's right okay i need to go back up going back i'm going
back
what yeah nearly there yeah okay that's interesting i found
it
or did i do it oh he's thank god we just got 100 oh this is
This is so scary.
We don't know what's going on in the refinery or what's
happening to Flamb.
Flamb's going to...
Ruben, what the fuck are we waiting for?
What's going on?
Still ready to rock, baby.
I can grab coffee.
Is it worth grabbing coffee to save Flamb?
I don't know what we need.
I think I can get the resting.
Okay, yeah, we can make it.
Alright, nice.
Um Is it more so for defense or I don't know I'm gonna get
both just to secure it Can you feel both It's defense?
Okay Putting golden man punch up Yeah I'm gonna do both He
feels all?
Do I just trust on golden?
Or should I put both?
Chat We gotta save him.
We need more people.
Like, I mean, I hope he doesn't die.
But also, we need more.
I can't handle it with four.
With three.
No punch up.
Oh, he does not feel that.
Okay.
Assembler.
If I was on do not disturb, I...
Anyway, what did I miss?
Oh, wait.
He's fine now.
Oh, not much.
Just the end of the fucking world.
Alright, we have four now.
Try and put a stop to that?
Get your ass in gear, babe.
We're putting in some mad OT.
Oh yeah, no, thank God.
Yeah, oh shit.
Yeah, I swear to God.
I swear to God.
I mean, I'm fast enough.
Oh, nice.
See?
Yeah, we brought it back!
Requesting backup.
We've got several 487s at the mall.
Enough armed looters.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
That should be everyone.
Oh, hey.
Okay, we gotta find depression, man.
Shit.
Signal split.
Can't look for them at the same time.
first depression man how do i pick sorry but i'm sorry look
sonar i'm sorry but he is worth more i'm sorry he is worth a
lot more
not going for the only guy that can think for
It's a risk I'm willing to take.
Out of range.
Is there like an electricity thing here?
No.
I'm in too deep.
Okay.
Have to make him...
Oh no.
Wait, what?
Intruder detectives.
Oh, shit!
I got so confused.
Okay.
I had to go...
Wait, what?
Oh, top, right?
Stay with me.
Oh.
Oh, now...
Oh, shit, sir!
I got confused.
Now what?
Top left now?
Oh, okay.
oh no
found it oh thank god okay okay okay okay we locked it I got
so confused I was like what it's okay we got him we got
Phenomenon okay we don't he's on a train being set wait what
before he's in another city wait why is he on a train oh I
didn't get the bonus I didn't remember oh wait I did get the
bonus I keep the this one is nice on the name we need
someone to fuse it immediately defuse the bomb who can
defuse a bomb okay we gotta we got they got him what do you
mean by that they just they just got him okay what was this
okay someone's smart um
so not good Fuck!
That's for this one.
We'll send these two.
We really need Phenomenon.
Someone's smart.
I'm gonna risk it a little bit.
I can maybe send two and then they'll be just as smart.
Okay, we're using the coffee.
Feeling fresh.
This is like my...
Okay, um...
Five intelligence.
Okay, we got five.
No, no way.
It's okay, guys.
Surely five intelligence is gonna save us.
Right?
Five.
Five powers combined.
We have...
By the powers combined.
Oh my god.
You've got a lot of explaining to do.
Look, I fucked up.
Really.
Really bad.
Alright, we got five.
Okay, okay, this is good.
Alright, now we can put B in a cage.
Wait, pull him up and rescue him?
Oh shit, okay.
No bullshit.
We need all the help.
This should rescue them together.
You're back in.
On one condition, you fucking survived this.
There you are.
at you together no promises she looks pretty bleak out there
should be fine my best that's more than enough okay okay yay
we did it i knew it okay guys i told you our average itq
combined together will save the world it's fine our trainees
are pissing themselves all right join sweet talk and
reassuring the trainees that they will not die i don't think
depression man can do out of that so give me a sex sweet
talker um i have flamb i i guess i got this he can talk a
little bit i'll wait a little i'll wait a little bit maybe i
can save him in time oh my god oh thank god we just made it
all right it's okay we got saving my life let's never speak
of this again we have sonar coming in very slowly oh god
he's not gonna make it okay um um flambay you know what yeah
you too that should be enough to talk to people all right uh
god you guys all need to be a little smarter
all right disrupted oh
Oh, eight.
Eight is a lot.
Eat us a lot.
Oh, thank God we just made it.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, thank God with the power of two.
With the power of two.
You have things all here.
Some of you in worse shape than others.
My whole life started to flash before my eyes.
See, look at that, guys.
We saved the city.
Like, 10% of the people in the city died.
But, like, 10% is 10%.
Oh, dang it.
The 90 live.
Oh, shit.
Water boy?
Give me one second.
Wait, am I recruited?
Is he?
Wait, is he gonna join my team?
I mean, he has the power of water.
in here water boy you're in yeah i um what what spill
something i use water guns that's not i i mean i i don't do
i what if somebody spills mess up i would mess up other
people the city is on fire you are the most valuable man in
los angeles no no no i i can't my my net worth
against fire.
Okay.
Great.
Galen.
Yes, sir.
Can we...
Okay.
You don't gotta keep saying it, okay, bud.
Can we get the newest Z-teamer water boy into the hero pool?
Absolutely.
How you feeling, man?
Okay.
Hell yeah, bro.
You sound okay.
Okay.
Squirtle, I choose you.
Water, boy.
Not to fear, worry, blazer.
She said you were, it was, um, um, I'm here to help.
All right, man, don't hurt yourself.
Glad to have you on the team.
Oh, why, if it isn't the SDN janitor?
I'm gonna get so wet.
Oh, okay.
Okay, Water, boy.
Oh, my God.
Okay, Water, okay.
Okay.
Oh, that, I know I'm not.
send golem steering the pier apart wait if i put him here
does he spread all the way here guess what does he spread
here yeah all right oh shit yeah that's right you do the
chad is using the chaos just some other god through human
sacrifice oh i sent her oh i got these dickheads and then
wait actually let me double check allison Expecting
explosives.
We need backup.
Oh, shit.
Put out the...
What?
What's happening?
Do you think Waterboy can solo this, guys?
It's his time.
It's okay.
He's soloed.
Okay, let's look at the other...
Get me on my jet right now.
Okay.
Fuck this shit.
It is...
It's his purpose.
Alright, what about you soloed this?
He gets soloed.
I believe in you.
I think he gets soloed this, guys.
Oh, did somebody else for Hellfire?
Should I copy her?
Just to be...
Yeah.
I'll copy her just in case.
I believe in water, boy.
Choosing each other or being red ring spies.
Um.
What?
We'll put you two together.
And then you.
I'll put.
Esquire.
You know what?
We can't escort each other.
Alright.
Let's see.
Let's see if Waterboy can solo this.
I.
It's fine.
Give me a sec.
I want to know.
They can be locked in a little bit longer.
longer break off the ring red oh wait let me think about
this oh I can't attack you everything break off isn't that
both combat which one is best guys which one does what break
what does attack is break is vigor okay so we have yeah we
have higher vigor okay all right we have higher
Okay, never mind.
I thought we...
All right, does he solo this?
Hmm...
There's no time for this.
Oh, okay.
I don't...
Okay, okay, guys.
He does, in fact, not solo this, guys.
Who would have thought?
All right, remember this.
Left, left, right, up.
Who would have thought?
I thought he would solo this.
I don't know.
I thought I would get the thing where you're like, yeah,
here you go.
Here's the electricity.
I was so confident.
I don't know why I felt like could be a hero.
I thought it was his time to shine, guys.
are you fucking oh yes what oh i can do this now he just
needs to warm up he's just scared oh oh oh this is oh
okay wait
i didn't realize that the wait what
wait what okay okay i'm a little confused How do I get over
there?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, no, this is bad.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh!
JK.
JK, JK, JK.
Oh, JK, JK, JK, JK.
It's making me super nervous, but JK, JK, JK.
Oh, we got it.
We got it.
I got a little nervous there.
I will rescue the students.
They didn't have to die.
Phenomenon!
Okay, I have charisma.
Is that rally them against the real enemy?
Because I assume reason with them is, like, thinking.
Does it rally?
Yeah, that was a little bit too close.
Is rally charisma?
Yeah?
Okay, yeah, we have 10 charisma.
charisma.
There's no way we could fuck this up.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
Okay, we were very much qualified.
I'll say it.
I really feel like I don't get enough credit around here.
Oh, my God.
Please, please.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, we just made it.
We just made it.
We were missing these two.
Okay, that's just tiny.
Alright.
Nice.
My might is unmatched.
Okay, everything's fine.
LA country county experiencing.
Oh, that is more...
Oh!
Oh, where are the other heroes?
Wait, all my other villains!
Went to...
Went home, went to work?
Whatever it is, it sounds like more shit.
Oh, shit.
What?
Everyone died there?
Get a load of my new friends.
Oh, no way.
That can't be.
wait who's injured i can't tell i'm not mad i'm just
disappointed oh these two i don't care golem why did you
have to go and spread those wings of yours we want to save
this city we need to take coop down without her the red ring
will scramble all right oh shit the okay Terrogate Coop.
Subjugate Coop's crew.
Why do I do that?
I wish to speak with Blonde Blazer about the terms of my
employment.
Water.
We are not sending in water, boy.
Punch up and mail?
Holy fuck.
Why?
Wait, why send in water?
We are not!
We are not sending in water!
He is not gonna solo, yes, my cute water boy.
Do we need interrogate?
Okay, interrogate.
Yeah, fuck them all.
Oh, we should nobody is.
Oh, wait, visit girl.
The girl that got her cut.
Let him solo.
Okay.
I think this is good.
Guys, look how much Waterboy increases this.
Like, I am.
Okay, you have to stop calling me that.
Punch up.
All right, we'll see.
I'm curious what will happen.
I'm curious.
Send her ass.
Do you?
Shit.
Red ring zooming out tech like it's candy.
There's a fuck ton of gangs wreaking havoc down here.
Secure the red ring tech.
Oh, is this?
Okay.
yeah oh i should have healed him oops squirrel will never
evolve a sign so we're not so he gains plus one bro why are
you okay we're gonna heal it we have to heal water boy yeah
there we go maybe okay there we go there you go he didn't
send himself in thank god okay yeah okay but he is the
second smartest all right i'm willing okay okay i'm there
that's all about thinking whoa okay that's a lot of ground
to cover all right here we go oh nice we did it second
smartest with three is crazy we've got another gang out here
with red ring tech bus secure you know what yeah that's
right i want to send i think okay i want to send Red rings
put up a roadblock.
Let's fucking tear it down.
Destroy the racer stuff for the oncoming.
We'll fire with Dario.
Wait, I feel like that needs defense, though.
Okay, let's check the other one.
I understand there are higher priorities.
Deliver a large ice matcha green tea light.
All right, we'll send the water boy for that.
All right, we're gonna put Flamb.
Call me a Bogo bitch.
We'll do these two.
They haven't been together in a while.
the same boarding buildings okay i think i can't wait a
little bit i'll wait a little bit robert got any z-teamers
nearby we got uber east during the uber east during the
during war carried that cannot carry themselves okay that
needs mobility everyone's like so far away i can wait a
little bit i think plus the east side
uh maybe these two but i am i need to send three people at
once okay did anything help tall no are you kidding me
really she always was a hell of a are you serious okay
that's fun that's fun That's rigged.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're almost there.
I swear to God if it went that way.
I swear to God.
Okay, we gotta have Mal.
And then my guy's depressed.
Okay.
Okay, this is not going so well for me.
He just suddenly got depressed.
Um, oh no.
Okay, Waterboy.
What do I put you with?
What do I even give Waterboy?
What do I even give him?
Intelligent?
Okay, he's gonna be my third smartest.
Oh my god, we'll go with this first.
We'll send you in here.
This will be your job.
And then we'll send you...
Oh god.
Oh fuck.
ignored the coffee the coffee is important okay you're gonna
do this you don't understand the coffee is so important wait
she's getting closer guys
wait why wait why is he waiting wait oh god okay
Oh, the checkmark?
Oh.
No.
No, you bet!
This is so...
Okay, this is fucked.
This is so fucked.
Okay, you better do this.
My money's on Blazer.
That is so fucked!
You're not allowed to bet on yourself.
Oh, damn.
Yeah, see, we did it.
We got coffee.
Oh, hey.
sweetly sweet thanks man what's the bet last one left alive
when all this shit goes straight to who i swear to god if it
goes down here i swear to god if it okay thank god we're
fine we're fine everything is fine um the red ring tech it's
mr fister defeat mr fister there you can i am i ready for
this yeah you're so ready as long as we stay clear that one
from this will be fine i need to be coop oh my god i with
who okay i'll send omniman in there
all right oh my god that is still oh nice we just made it
okay okay nice increased chances okay nice
I'm trying to figure out who to send We're gonna put He's
almost less depressed guys I have an idea We'll send him in
Could be worse And then there we go There we go this will
work I'm really gonna enjoy this Alright What the fuck What
the fuck Are you fucking?
Oh, thank God.
We did it.
The 49% wins again.
Get the fuck back up.
What the fuck are you doing?
We did it.
Intelligence, mobility.
You know what?
We'll make you fast.
Okay, the closest is this way.
We can the bridge.
Hurry to the tornado.
Do I have anyone that's fast?
Okay, you're just gonna be fast for...
Oh, wait, we do.
Okay.
You're fine.
Um...
Help.
We're trapped inside of the stadium.
Okay, we're gonna let...
These kids are gonna...
No, it's a danger, but we pay good money for this service.
What else could possibly be keeping you?
Alright, we should save the children.
I was like, we don't need to save the kids.
And I'm like, oh, wait.
We should save the children.
I...
Like, after we stop all this bullshit.
I mean, sure.
I don't think no one knows...
We can wait a little bit.
There's no one in actual immediate danger.
Like...
Yeah, it's just a housing crisis.
What's gonna happen there?
It's fine.
Oh, my God.
Oh, thank God.
I sent a lot of people in.
Are you fucking...
Okay, thank God.
Forget the children.
I was gonna say, does it really matter?
Talk about impatient.
Alright.
Come on.
Nice.
Yeah, baby.
We're the motherfucking bridge now.
Trying to brainwash the citizens with her red ring implant.
Smile, Marissa, you can convince her enemy to only so much
strong metal.
Oh, okay.
We gotta send him.
in or i'll send you in that's good wait consider my feelings
next time i feel like i can only send no we can't someone
with strong mental fortitude just him yeah i feel like
too much talking is bad yeah that's why he's just thinking
water boy with so not okay let's see if we have enough time
no we don't That red ring creeps smile more took over the
radio.
I can't, I can't look at him.
He's still, he's EP.
We can't always said water boy.
Also creepy, which is also hot.
Protect the well-being, but defenses against your
overpowered.
Okay, we gotta wait then.
All right, did we do anything?
Oh.
I forgot he was depressed, so he didn't go.
What the fuck?
Fuck?
He was depressed.
Watch mobilizing against the red rain.
No.
I thought he'd be okay.
You're not in my city.
Okay.
Yeah.
Goodbye city.
I think the city's fucked.
Guys.
I forgot that he was depressed.
Yeah.
Okay.
Are your augments on the fritz?
What the fuck is going on?
I'm trying my best, guys.
But he keeps being depressed.
I don't understand.
Why are you depressed?
Convince them to turn back.
Okay, which one is combat phenomenal aim?
Okay.
just don't be sad send in against coop now oh my god why why
i could have killed her if he
wasn't he is helpful but he's just you gotta go solo dolo
when they count the most we're just failing slower that's
how i feel bro they gotta stretch him bro hitting us
everywhere no kind of way you're right hey listen up this
isn't working this is what they want okay to send us to
every corner of the city spreading us then forcing us to
travel back and forth no more coming back to base between
calls yeah we stay out for as long as we can see a plan is
for us to get more tired than we already are oh he knows our
procedure so he's predicting our moves so we need to switch
it up be less guys i don't think i'm going to win this guys
we'll live on and Guys, we proved I had to tweak that damage
group once.
Okay.
I wish to speak with Blund Blazer about the terms of my
employment.
Oh.
Villains abound.
Oh, God.
Keep them coming.
Here?
That doesn't hit it, right?
Does this work?
Anyone but yeah, okay.
Okay, go, go, go, go.
It'll be the last thing you see.
Please let us off.
Rescue the civilians from canned air.
Destroy all.
Reach civilians before their mob.
Okay, you can't be depressed.
You can't be depressed.
Do not be depressed.
Okay, he made it.
He made it guys.
He made it.
He's fine.
He's not depressed guys.
He made it He made it Wait Beefcake didn't we fight her last
week and has your ability red ring your get back in here Hit
beefcake hard and fast.
Okay, far and wait can she heal herself?
Let's rub them up That's fine Oh, you know what I can do
I'll send their friends.
There you go.
What's it going to be this time?
Send him and find!
I will my heart.
He can join in.
All right.
This should be 100%.
Okay.
86%.
I swear to God, if I fail at 86%, I swear to God.
I swear to God.
Oh, God, okay.
How much damage?
Oh, that is.
not a lot but that's fine send sonar down here right now
okay i've got a knife picked out just for him i got this oh
i'm gonna wait a little bit i'm gonna wait a little bit yo
we've got a plan but we need backup we could actually turn
this around our head constructed trapage window okay we're
gonna wait a little bit because i need to send people back
um okay
serious heat out there you're done for this should be fun
right Mal in prison we out here you know this yeah but she's
injured and oh I have a band-aid thank God okay no worries
what the fuck is going on I don't remember what she was best
I feel like These two, right?
Six?
This should be fine, right?
Mel and Sonar?
Oh, you're right.
I forgot they have killed.
Yeah, but it doesn't do well.
Because we don't have vigor, combat, or mobility.
That has the most reach, I feel like.
Wait, which one was it?
Punch-up.
Holy shit, fuck.
Yeah, but, like, I don't trust him.
He's going to get depressed.
gonna it is gonna get he's gonna increase chances okay i
trust you guys i swear to god if they fuck it up again if
they fuck this up they're never being together anymore i
don't care about god damn friendship don't know when to quit
do you construct a trap who's smart enough let's go bitches
all right you guys have the bonus oh shit first mistake wait
where did he go
fucking kidding me you said hit hard and fast where oh he's
out oh yeah i've got you oh thank god okay laser thank god
oh thank god thank god thank god damn blazers here golems
out golems fucking out right now and i just can't help
myself well that's great because i'm in deep ship pretty
much constantly my house i was not expecting to see my
former lover at a time like this Oh, no.
My health.
Oh, no.
Oh, my health.
Um.
Get hot.
Bombay.
Think you can handle this convoy?
Oh, I don't know.
Would you call a wall of fire?
Oh, I can rest.
I forgot I can rest.
I will revive.
Set fire.
Okay.
Red Ring has attacked the Vincent Thomas Bridge and is now
escaping on the USS Iowa.
Need assistance in the pursuit?
Oh, no.
Who's fast?
Phenomenal.
Guess what?
This is fat.
Okay.
Don't be depressed.
It becomes larger.
Yeah.
Are you...
I'm never sending...
I'm never sending those two out.
Oh, they got...
Oh Oh thank god oh thank god Oh thank god oh thank god Oh
thank god Oh thank god okay
Oh my god everyone's injured How can I help I'm on standby
Everyone's hurt Everyone's hurt Help we're trapped on the
bridge You do this.
I like being so hands-on again.
I mean, the citywide chaos isn't great, but, you know.
I forgot about...
Okay, okay.
I forgot about Bla- I have Blazer.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, we send Blazer into this.
We have to send...
Wait, can I even send Blazer?
Oh, I can't send Blazer into this.
Because she only wants to see Blazer.
okay she actually has to heal someone
still in my feet okay
let them in again okay I swear to god I swear to god guys
they fuck it up I swear to god
oh my god bro her stats are fucking crazy okay Red Ring
stole one of our news copters.
They're firing out of civilians.
You know what?
You can go in.
Take that copter out now.
Helicopters are annoying on the best of days.
I'll just send blonde blazer everywhere.
Alright.
Oh, come on.
What?
How did it fail?
When did it trigger it?
Why?
It's green!
We saw it!
The synergy guys!
I told you!
Shit, fuck.
Okay.
I was talking.
I told you.
I fucking told you.
I knew it.
Okay.
I just don't have intelligence.
It won't go on the other side, right?
Guys, it's not going to go.
It's because he got healed.
Yeah, but then the defense.
I'm scared about the vigor and the intelligence guys
Oh, there's no intelligence Okay
But let's predict though Punch bus VC You're done for I
mean, it's the most equal You predict is intelligent Evade
is speed and strike is come Oh, okay Alright, we have five
this should be fine we have five I'm really gonna enjoy this
I can't she healed him and it fucked me over I can't believe
it she healed him I'm so sad like she actually healed him
and it ruined everything I'm putting intelligence come
on come on we so come on we could do this guys 50 maybe 60
percent of the city is dead but it's okay it's okay everyone
we'll be fine the red ring has overwhelmed me i need
immediate assistance okay you go over here wait i have to
hit all of that for hellfire And then...
I heal Sonar again.
He's damaged, right?
Is that damaged?
And then I'll heal you too.
I'm healing all two of you.
You have to stop calling me that.
Wait, uh...
Can she heal more than one person?
Or only one person?
You can only heal one?
Who do we heal?
Will heals water, boy.
It's only one.
What is the red thing?
Do I have to hit the red to...
Do I have to be, like, not on the red?
What is this red thing?
No, if I don't, we don't succeed!
Oh, Waterboykin!
Oh, red is her ability?
I forgot what her ability...
Wait, what was her ability?
Wait.
Where is...
Oh, power.
Oh, the next stab, the next call.
Oh, okay, so I have to be here.
have to be closer okay i'll send golem fuck it yeah yeah
i'll send golem in so i can i'll heal water boy and then
send golem in i'm doing this to heal him i don't care i hate
that part of town and all parts of all other towns also use
the bomb this is oh my god you got this okay we're sudden
you're diffusing this pop you're diffusing this pop i don't
think i don't think sonar sonar is gonna get it sonar is not
diffusing anything someone's messing with our systems okay
it's fine i want to know this first before i do the hack
guys we're not guys no i'm not i'm not lose i please guys
you're gonna help me for this pretend we can well i wonder
if i have anyone in chat that can predict the future okay
you're not helping me because you're you're you're all oh
yellow red 100 red red red red what color is it's random
okay red ring oh my god yellow for dokey oh
thank god yellow is intelligence
okay oh my god oh my god
there's no way there's
and visigal's on her way back to sdn okay that we'll make do
there is actually no way let's lock in there's no fucking
way there's no there's no way are you fucking kidding me
wait what what uh I hate this i that's actually so what's
going on huh it's a path ah can't follow me here can you
hang on something's wrong with my controls oh no oh no i
hate this it's inverted down I'm already going through so
much, man.
Like, are you serious?
I'm so over.
I'm so over this.
Oh my god.
I'm so over it, guys.
I'm actually so over.
like my luck is so fucking bad i'm so sad i'm just i there's
just oh my god there's actually no way that happened to me
you ain't ready for this i don't know like i'm so sad i'm so
sad How am I that unlucky?
How am I actually?
They're mine.
Oh no.
Yeah, we're- I'm on it.
If all else fails, we send in.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's just expand though.
They burn down Los Amigos.
And no one else gets the Tostata shell as crispy.
Senyele.
You know what?
Why do I go in there?
Don't even try it.
Atop of the morning.
Oh, I'm so sad.
I thought our old commute was shit.
I'm so sad.
I'm so fucking sad.
I'm so unlucky.
How am I that unlucky?
Atop of the morning to you.
Alright, I mean, there's no way I failed this It take up the
entire grid
Yeah, I covered the entire grid on a single call Come on
Thank God you're not depressed anymore This is the longest
night shift of my life I have to know what this is
It's been a We made it!
We made it!
I
don't think so.
Okay, okay, we've made it in.
We've made it.
Fucking rocks.
Okay, it's this, the prediction.
There's, okay, good.
We got the prediction in.
Team first.
Okay, we got it.
We have it.
It's winnable!
It's okay.
Art.
the red ring just go in for i am your doom all right blonde
laser you go in that's 100 right there okay okay it's it's
winnable it's winnable we have hope are you kidding me so
hot sonar you gotta dig deep dug all i can man well that
sounds like quitter talk didn't know harvard grads were
quitters are you serious take that back i will after we win
oh no he's not okay oh no we don't have we don't have second
chance
oh no he's out our our smartest man is out i thought they
aren't supposed to be quitters get your shit in gear send
Malin.
Okay.
Okay, we gotta boost you up.
You are the smartest guy left that we have.
Like, you have to be our guy.
Okay.
There's no way.
18% That's happened two times!
I I don't think I can salvage this, guys.
I don't know if I can...
Oh my god.
Man, this is...
Ow!
Okay.
Okay!
This is...
Overall!
The...
That's fine.
Okay.
Scanning by.
I can heal him.
Okay.
Again.
We go.
Just restart.
I guess LA doesn't want to get saved.
No.
It'll be fine.
He's not.
Depression man is no longer depressed.
We can stop her.
Served you right for cutting Cupid in the first place.
God, you were the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm, the thing is, we've been doing this for so long.
Nothing, like, this is it.
This is the only thing we're waiting on.
There's no way.
Okay, thank God.
I was gonna say if I fuck up the 90% There is Just pull this
off There's no way This is literally It's just me and her
Give her everything you've got Can I say oh god okay Okay
Okay Come on now No I can't What if he leaves Can I send
blonde blazer Can I send her?
I need a no.
If you are sure, I'm willing.
Okay,
okay, okay, okay, okay.
I've been stuck in this area for so fucking long to a point
where they stopped giving me missions.
It's literally just coop.
I've been stuck on her for so long.
I don't even get missions anymore.
Fucking Phenomenon has been drifting around here for 20
years because I'm worried he's going to get depressed.
Oh my god.
His name is not Togeeper.
I found an 80% chance like three times take a deep breath oh
thank god the entire city of la versus one woman 70 of the
citizens of la has died but it's okay not good bro
i even failed a 95 percent that's crazy
trace solid thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
try an exorcism or getting your house cleansed by priest
funds because what the actual fuck you need bro i've been so
unlucky this year has actually been so bad to me
he's fine
All right, take care of him.
What?
I trusted you, Vizzy.
You were wrong for this.
I defended for you.
Fucking put me down.
I didn't do anything.
No, no.
I caught you.
I caught you red-handed.
She said go over there.
If I was doing that, use your head.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, this before Bros.
Roy, let her go, man.
No, brother.
She ain't going nowhere.
she tries to steal your mech suits oh off and break my heart
brother but vizzy is a traitor she played all of us that's
not what i was doing i'm trying to help you i trusted you
wait is roy a bad guy whoa whoa
holy is that the real she bring the keys to steer the car
but i stop her you fucking idiots you need me you brought
the astropulse you already do enough you don't know what's
coming what are you talking about
oh what for here i
thought she was cool
oh there's cool but i beat you up
fuck we under attack watcher don't get the power back you
need my help you helped enough i going no wait fire up my
super suit i don't know what wait i fire up my suit i'm
gonna get my suit on what do i call the z team trust the oh
i choose i'm gonna fire up my suit i need my suit where is
my super suit they have jammers up you're not going to be
able to call out or call in that's why this place isn't
already swarming with heroes you sure know a lot about the
plan for someone not involved look they tried to recruit me
of course they did but i said no bullshit watch her i go get
the power back on i moved your mecha man's suit to the rec
room here take this
We're fighting the red ring, right?
I'm not walking home from fucking yoga.
All I got, brother.
Thank you, dingy.
I got
some pepper spray you can borrow if that's not enough.
No, Mr. Whiskers.
All right, untie me.
What?
Why are you looking?
You didn't lie to me, but you didn't tell me the truth.
She omitted information.
Why didn't you tell me?
I just don't understand why you wouldn't tell me.
I was worried Shroud would come after you.
Well, he did.
So if I gave it to you, he'd have the pulse right now.
I was trying to protect you.
Aww, that's so sweet.
Yeah, but at least I didn't die.
You did great, girl.
Thanks for giving me.
internal bleeding at least i didn't die thumbstick what it's
his name because he sticks you with what thumbs around untie
me he looks stupid but he is a killer you don't have powers
you need my help just untie her no hesitation two versus one
is better to be one i'm looking for something to cut you
loose but his toolboxes are locked What did he do that for?
Oh, I fucking wonder, Vizzy.
Why would he lock up his tools around invisible criminal
thieves?
Robert!
Boy, there's a lot of people coming down now.
Oh, great.
Good.
I've trusted her this far.
Are we in kindergarten?
Guys, there's no going back.
I can't be like...
There's no backsees.
I've already stuck my neck out for her.
We still haven't hooked up yet.
I'm fully committed.
I will get the IRL hookup.
Oh, shit.
It's a quick time event time.
What?
Does he not see me?
He needs
to use the bathroom.
I
hate this place.
God, come on.
Open it.
Come on.
Alright, alright.
Fuck it.
Okay.
Oh, why don't you pee before you come here?
Oh, shit.
While they're peeing, I feel like I should...
I feel like I should get the gun first.
Oh, I would...
I could...
It would shock his dick, though.
Oh.
Oh, I guess if it was like...
If I didn't untie her, she would have...
Ew.
If I didn't untie her, I had to use that.
Nice job.
why are his nuts out oh thought that was normal you mind
helping him why would you crinkle cut your balls through
your zipper if you don't have what are you asking me can you
just put his dick away feels like the dignified thing to do
oh for who I know the guy a little and it's bad enough he's
unconscious I'll show you fuck all right piss everywhere
yeah thank you that was very decent of you
don't worry i'll do it for her do it for her oh shit i'm
surprised no one shot him yet go get your suit wait
shouldn't we stick together when she does that
why didn't no one shoot him
robert is now gay that's all it takes you touch one one ball
And now you gay.
It's the gateway drug.
That's the rule.
Yeah, the gateway drug.
Not the
only one guy has a gun.
Oh, there it is.
God, these guys are really bad shots.
Like, they have little enhancers, you know?
game i did it it might have accidentally shot him but i did
it mecca man
oh shit i look like an actual um power like look at gundam
or power ranger or there's some actual mecca shit oh he's so
stretchy this is great bro why is he always naked obviously
the suit doesn't work without the astral pulse so it is
really nice of you to bring it to us your dad would be so
proud of you if he wasn't dead because shroud killed him
like he's gonna kill you and all your friends that Break
their fuck, you are.
Oh, there he is.
Oh.
Break all their arms right before we kill them.
Super weird crime scene.
Or just give us the pulse and we'll let you live.
With broken fucking arms.
Of course.
Oh, God.
Each.
Each one gets broken.
Everyone gets it.
Okay.
Where's Shroud?
You're making it weird.
Is that where you're asking?
Yeah.
I don't care about you guys.
What the fuck am I waiting for?
Hey Shad.
It's like real big but super quiet.
So cool.
These players are crazy.
Oh shit, what the fuck?
Your dad said he'd help me build a Mac if I helped him build
the Astral Pulse.
Just another promise he didn't control on.
Told you I knew it how are your stupid spider shit.
I've said in the beginning He I knew he made I had a feeling
he made the astral post like plugging your cell phone into a
nuclear reactor No hard to do that when you're dead I knew
it is going to be hard to pull off after I kill you Huh?
Oh They don't like that How did he know
Energy blades Melee time Oh, sure, one for gut bullet
Because it's cooler Wait, what?
Oh, shit, I got confused I got confused with the cutscene
With the quick time event
Okay, that quick time event confused me It was so fast
Gun versus sword, let's go It is cooler, though.
Cluster bomb!
That's looking right.
Bro, he's stream sniping me.
He's like screen peeking.
Okay, he's a lot bigger.
That new car shine.
Blonde Blazer!
You were late.
My calculations had you showing up 30 seconds ago.
Sorry to disappoint.
Oh, never mind.
I can't tell you how boring life is without surprises.
Well, then it's a good thing I can't even predict what these
idiots are gonna do.
Wait, the Z-Team?
Oh!
Oh, it's Prism!
Let's go!
Z Team!
With the power of friendship!
Oh yeah, no, he's dead.
Yeah, no, he's fucking dead.
Z Team assemble!
Okay, baby.
It doesn't matter if I'm fighting one or all of you.
The outcome is the same.
Okay.
Okay, I'm more aware now of these quick time events.
Bro, it doesn't even matter.
They just dodge everything.
Oh, God.
Waterboy.
Oh, man.
Damn, waterboy.
boy
Oh shit Oh my god reflection with the power wambles He
touched one ball Now it's everywhere Too slow.
Do you mean I hit?
How am I too slow?
I hit it!
I actually hit it!
What happens when I don't hit the quick time event?
It can't be slow anymore!
I hope my saving from collision was appropriate.
It was phenomenal.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Nice shot.
You know what?
I definitely had that.
Oh, great.
Well, I'll just go then.
Bro, no jokes, guys.
We're fighting people.
Guys, come by.
We never finished our dance, Mecha Man.
Actually, I got the guy for you.
Oh.
Wow, you really think this little fucking lucky charm is a
match for me?
He's got a special move.
What is it?
Oh, ball punch!
Oh, because his dick's out!
No, ending the bloodline today.
Where'd you come from?
Oh shit, shit.
He asked- he didn't calculate this.
I see you.
He's a bull.
He should be fine, right?
Robert, this isn't working.
He knows our next move before we- Oh, he keeps stream
sniping us.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, it's cool.
Wait, what do we do?
I've never been more insulted in my life.
You fire me.
A literal assassin for some moronic bum fuck bad boy.
Yeah, but he has a degree.
Did you know that?
Ask the cleaners how much guano they come across.
Looks like I was right, though.
By the looks of things.
I made the right decision.
That's right.
Um, he has a very successful YouTube channel.
What do you have?
Yeah, do you have a degree?
I hit it!
What happens if I don't hit it?
What's the point of me succeeding quick time events if I
still get it?
You're not the boss of me, bitch.
So you don't get to tell me who and who not to murder
anymore.
Hey.
We're your friends.
Please, this isn't you.
Help us stop Shroud and earn your spot back on the Z-Team.
That's where you're wrong.
I thought I had friends.
But you made me realize I never actually did.
So now, I'm just doing what's right for me.
Oh, shit.
Z-Team.
What a stupid name.
No,
I'm not fix I have to fix someone else right now.
I can't fix two people I'll try to get you an opening Guys,
I can't fix everyone I have I'm at my limits
One one lady prefix
There you go.
Five wings.
Is she gonna die?
Oh, oh.
Wait, but I hit it.
Did not hit it?
Oh shit!
Yay!
Flying people.
Okay, stay focused.
Sorry, I'm gonna stay focused.
Laugh forever.
Oh, shit.
Bye, arm.
Calm down.
It was your weak hand.
You can still jerk off.
Maybe if you grip it with the seven one, hold it with...
Yeah, you know what?
Fair enough.
It's not even his real arm.
He's fine.
Just attach another arm.
What?
No!
Oh, he wanted...
Oh!
It'll be fine, right?
Oh my god.
I'm trying to find...
I'm locking in so hard.
Oh my god, this scene is so well done.
This scene is sick as fuck, though.
The animation for the fight.
Oh my god, I'm playing Osu!
Yeah, I was like, wait, this is Osu!
Okay.
Yeah, you are.
What?
Chase?
How long was I out?
Blazer?
What the fuck happened?
Wait, she...
You're not the only one who wasn't born with powers.
Wait.
She gave it to Chase?
Holy shit.
Look at you.
Oh, look at you.
What?
She's not blocked.
She's not a muscle ma- Everything was a lie.
Everything was a fucking lie.
She was never a muscle ma- Hazel always did have a soft spot
for helpless losers.
Fuck off.
It's so, it's over.
Oh shit!
Fast NATO!
I guess, I don't know how he didn't predict the old.
I guess he didn't think the old man was in the equation.
Fuck.
I'm going to make love to you.
You a hoi.
You such a hoi.
Bro, you just hugged everyone?
I thought we were special.
Oh my god, we're not special.
Oh, you didn't know about Blazer's powers?
Oh!
I see.
You didn't realize what Blazer's actual powers come from.
Wait, why did the middle finger get censored?
I said profanity okay.
Oh, shit.
I looked at chat for one second.
Super spirit bomb!
Yeah!
Raise your hands!
we fucked them in the face
i like how yeah it changes the hairstyle too why what
happened i still look good right oh nice nice ass soccer
player is going through something
Oh?
Track star.
Well, that is a surprise.
Please.
How did he get...
How did he get beef?
This fat buck.
No!
Why is everyone so tense?
Don't worry.
I'm not gonna drop him.
Because track blonde, if they're just swooping and catch him
anyway.
What a monster.
oh I'm killing this oh
Oh I feel like if I threaten him he's gonna kill the dog
I'll be like I'll do whatever you want Oh my god I'll do
whatever you want because like I feel like if I yeah Yeah,
because, like, if I say if you drop him, I'll threaten him.
If I threaten him!
If I threaten him, he'll kill the dog.
Threatening him?
Okay.
I'm not sure he dies.
Know this.
If you hurt him, you will die.
I'm like, John Wickless.
No, shit.
And give me my fucking astral pulse.
Okay.
He can still watch.
He got his dick punched.
We're a dog?
Come on out.
Don't be shy.
Sloppy guy is your weakness.
I knew you'd fall for.
What is it you call her?
In physical.
You knew?
That she'd steal that soft heart of yours like everything
else she's robbed.
Bro, that's why we planted her here.
She thought she had a chance with me.
she she thought she had a chat she's like what you hooked up
with envisaged and not me she works for us too she gets two
paychecks for the same job look at her oh she's embarrassed
so all that to say there isn't a thing you can do that i
haven't modeled out and once i have the pulse i won't need
to predict i'll just know don't fuck around robert not right
now what she didn't love me but like did you make her have
those sexy dreams about me too monster just don't be an
idiot and try to give me the shitty prototype i'm a bad
person but i'm a man of my word give me my pulse and no harm
will come to hear that oh i've been through all the game
theory on this moment a thousand times and that's the game
theory that's the theory
i'm gonna give him both because one explodes right so i give
him both you won't know what the fuck is this robert you
said you wanted the astropulse I gave it to you.
One of those is it's...
They look fucking identical, Robert.
Look, you're right.
I can't outsmart you.
Yeah, but he doesn't remember which one's fake.
You know what?
I'm not a smart guy.
Yeah, I'll be like, I don't know.
The only way to keep you from knowing what I'm doing is to
not have any idea what I'm doing, which is how I feel all
the time.
But I trust my gut, and I take my best guess, just like it
used to do.
Before you plugged all those fucking Christmas lights head
before you were afraid to make your own decisions Elliot
Maybe we wait till we get home shut the fuck up Yeah, that's
right you got rng Oh, that was the right one wasn't it?
Why oh He chose wrong.
You chose poorly.
I think I rage baited him, didn't I?
There's no way he wins the 50-50.
What the fuck?
Feel that, you fucking fucks.
I told you.
I fucking told you, Clouds.
of a power i see it now i can see it all how does he there's
no way there's no way
is that the prototype fuck wait just a hunch but i'm
starting to think that you guessed wrong yeah he loves the
gotcha let's go Let's go!
We did it!
If I can't win the gotcha, no I can!
You know, someone has to clean it up, right?
Let's go back and get the other one.
Don't be mad.
You lost.
Your RG is so, it's so bad it cursed Ralph too.
Baby, I think it was super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Someone will save us, right?
Oh, what?
She stood in front of the bullet What Oh it's her shoulder
She's fine It's fine It's a shoulder Like that's just me
It's fine
It's the shoulder She's okay Oh my god Oh my god!
Holy shit!
I'm Robbie!
Kill him!
Yeah!
Do it!
I'm Robbie!
Okay, you guys can't be like no hesitant i was saying from
the very start i'm gonna kill this man i no backsies
i told you i never said i was i always told you guys i was
gonna kill him since the very beginning when they asked are
you gonna kill him and i'm like yes why the would i suddenly
go no like
We're not doing Batman rules here From Batman I've learned
That you have to kill
Do it It doesn't make it right My grandfather and dad are
dead How
am I the one on a stretcher When you look like hammered shit
Be that as it may You did get shot by a gun little check is
pretty customary after that it didn't hit anything yeah well
it went straight through that's what i said quick hero
lesson when you jump in front of a bullet you're supposed to
actually stop it you know it's kind of the whole point
imagine she actually shot this at someone you should let a
nice moment be nice every now and then lie to someone.
Hey, chill out, girls.
I'm right.
As I choke someone to death.
I love it.
You know, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
This is a super chat.
This is just a precaution.
Look, all of this was a real bolster fuck.
Shit show, actually.
I was going to say poop show, but I'm trying to sound like
less of a dork.
It's already working.
I hope the fact that I've always rooted for you makes up
forever doubting you You wanted to cut her you lie I don't
blame you I mean look I know what you are There's always a
home for you here, Courtney I appreciate that I know what
you are, you lie You wanted to cut it twice
So here we are looks like you did it what is the it you're
referring to a lot really you're not a bitch apparently at
least according to them oh what do they know very little
yeah but there's also all that you know really heroic shit
you did saving my life and all you're a hero does that make
you a hero now no I think might though oh you got something
on here oh he's gonna chase he's gonna she kiss me whoa oh
water boy oh now that's not sensei is it still there i'm in
i did it take care of her i did it it took me seven eight
episodes i'm finally in
finally this was the slow the slowest burn of my life holy
shit she took a bullet for Robert something I would never do
it was a targeted attack by Shroud and those miserable jerks
the red ring there's a story out there that Shroud was
killed by not a superhero but an SDN dispatcher care to
comment I fixed it we did it guys See, it's possible.
Bitch Shroud deserve what he got.
Shit, can I not cuss?
It's fine.
We can bleep it out.
Manny!
Point the camera over.
These are the real heroes right here.
This is the team that thwarted Shroud in the bedroom.
Does your team have a name?
The Z team.
Z team!
These fuckers are the best heroes and the whole
motherfucking SD.
Actually, I'm hearing now we can't split the curse reporting
live from back to the studio we did good our brother brother
I couldn't have done it without you seriously all the work
you put into the suit is what made this alien gal to my left
it's not the hard part all you guys do the hard things well
no obviously you can do that stuff too i saw you were
throwing those red ring fuckers around like graduation caps
no joke i started to feel bad for them it was mesmerizing
yep that was a fun scrap for sure i'm kissing sleep bro not
a clean up tomorrow good job mecca man
over here oh is blonde blazer gonna be like a regular girl
now No, no, no, no, must be some mix-up.
Easy mistake.
I mean, she looks scary.
Oh, they're freeing her.
Did they earn a pardon?
Is that my call?
You're the one that'll have to work with them.
Forgive.
Wait, is forget bad?
For- is- Forget is like I let her go to prison forever,
right?
What if I- Ha ha ha ha!
Hmm.
How much do you want her back, chat?
Give us the one.
I gave you Invisigal.
I chose her over my boss.
What do you mean?
Give her one.
So demanding.
chat.
It's kind of bad, though.
But like good bad or bad, bad.
We don't negotiate.
Paturess is even a super chat.
Thank you.
I did fix.
I don't want it that bad.
Sorry, good time for braves again.
It's like, you know, you know, someone's above to go to jail
but like you know a very important person can stop someone
from going to jail when they're offered the right thing she
wasted so much time lock her away and throw away the key
yeah thank you for the super chat thank you thank you do it
for jack did she almost ruin your dispatch next thing is
super chat thank you thank you certified.
All right.
Who's paying her bail?
Who's...
Who wants to pay her bail?
All right.
I could save her for so that, you know, our boy Jack here
can you know, you know, have a win in his life.
Do it for punch up.
Okay, okay.
We'll forgive.
All right.
You're lucky.
You're so lucky Your bill's been paid No, they're with us
Oh nice Forgive your She'll 3% gift you next to me Which he
breaks out Here is Bill money Look gross This thing is super
chatty Thank you You're lucky your bills got paid Hey so You
maybe got an extra one of those Kill Shroud for his spirits
because coop was hot i wasn't can't control my good
they see bad hot lady and they're like i can fix it i got it
of course open beers like normie i was gonna keep her in
prison but then you guys paid her bell i've had half a beer
and i'm coop is just so hot dokey
so is that permanent nah he's borrowing it until we can
figure out a different solution for his issue right the
whole being on the brink of death issue that's the one well
looks like he'll enjoy while it lasts so do you feel better
yeah he got she got pretty privileged after killing shroud
yeah Robert it feels great look i want to do that again i'm
surprised to hear that but i suppose i'm happy for you yay
murder was great bro i should let you know that you're
suspended pending an investigation toky
you did a great job with them with invisigal she said she's
happy for me guys I took a bullet for you and everything.
I wouldn't have put my money on this team being the one to
save SDN, but...
We're just getting started.
Getting them to not be assholes to each other is the start,
not the end.
A lot left to do.
Yeah, well.
Take tonight to enjoy it.
You can worry about what's left to do tomorrow.
Yeah, my boss gave me the okay.
Murder is fine.
We have to talk to HR about that.
We have HR!
I haven't thought about that.
I'm joking.
Oh, thank God.
HR's a joke.
Thank fucking God.
Best joke of the night.
So we're good.
Having HR.
More than good.
Make her happy.
Because God knows she's fucking miserable.
Jesus.
But that's my girlfriend.
I'm fixing her.
So does this mean the team's off Monday?
I was just trying to figure that out.
Robert sucks.
I think you might need to go.
I need to take this young man if you don't mind.
By all means.
Robert sucks.
I was wrong about business.
She didn't actually kill me.
Just almost.
Now let's see if I can make you throw up.
What?
Wait, how did I somehow end up with a good ending?
I thought you guys said I'm destined for a bad ending.
This is pretty good.
I told you.
I'm wrong.
I told you guys I'm Robin that was the best choice I barely
saved it I told you I do it I was like I fight no no matter
what Robert wins
I saved it
How many endings do they have
Never punished I told you never punished oh two Four?
Wait, what are two?
Four?
Is it two or four?
All right, what are the four endings?
Was mine the best ending?
Oh, two romance endings, two good or bad.
Thought Squad.
That's a good name.
Been a nice finishing night game with you, Joki.
Story was great, but the dispatch gameplay seems
disconnected.
Looking forward to the next game.
Thank you for the super chat, Anna.
Thank you.
On random.
Thank you for the 10 gifted chips.
Thank you.
Since you romance and kept invisible.
Doki was just rage baiting us with all those losses, guys.
She had it all.
See, I had it all under control.
Guys, I always had it all under control.
So I was like, thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, the other ending of God was just like, um, um,
invisible.
out being a villain right like i could just made her a whole
villain and that would have been the bad ending oh
vc becomes shroud in the bad ending oh she takes over that's
right oh yeah i didn't like i didn't want i don't think i
would like that ending because that means we wouldn't have
hooked up i can't thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you Yeah, I would have liked that ending because we
wouldn't have hooked up in the end All right, the seed
shroud.
Okay, we gave him both I'm a go-killer.
Okay, a lot of us killed him see it's not that bad.
We all killed him Well, not all but like it's not that bad
of a percentage Crazy thank you super chat.
Thank you.
Six totems for matching up without a gallery and both of
them or just French loan or both of them Then there is a
miss takes the bullet for you or murder sharp Shroud.
Name of the Super Shroud.
Thank you.
If I go with both of them, will both of them, like, hook up
with both of them, like, polygamy?
Or would they be mad at each other?
See, you and 51% players say true to your word and kill
Shroud.
I told you I was gonna kill him.
Oh, no?
Aw.
It's complicated.
Only VC.
Okay, oh, Miz will hate you.
Trust in.
2v1, guys.
Support and letting her to embrace heroism.
Oh, this will be villainy.
Okay, we got the sunset.
Don't be greedy.
Yay!
This is 60%.
I'll end up maidenless if I did, but...
Rescue Phenomenon first over Sony.
Okay.
yeah no i would say that was a mistake phenomenal depression
man disappointed mailed me there he got depressed when i
needed him the most um rice thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you thank you over your d save sake day
yippee uh we welcome also 30% didn't pay the bell
unfortunate went on the coffee put a me at 36% But oh wait,
this is D.
I performed better than 70%!
Fuck you!
Still better than 70% of players after everything.
How?
No fucking shot.
That's a fucking...
right i still did better there is no way definitely you a
super chat that you thank you it's funny one is to bribe you
for coop but depending on certain things bomb these are
still censored censored to jail thank you the super chat
that you think yeah that's right i lost three 80 plus rates
and like double by the way there were ones because sonar had
the Double spin ability.
So there were times where I've lost 280% in a, like, like
twice in one, in one instance.
Because he has double chance.
That was the worst part.
You barely succeeded a call.
And every man you're robber always kept everyone guessing
what he'll say.
What he'll say or do next?
That's me.
For him better than...
Yay!
Look at that.
I prefer them better than 7% of theirs.
Across all ships, too.
You barely succeeded.
Ship was the last episode.
Oh, phase two.
That was phase two.
I did not feel like the most successful.
I'm Robert.
I'm Robert, guys.
That's insane.
I can't, but I'm so good at this game.
wow that was fun i understand the hype now i had oh yeah um
one of my friends um who's obsessed with dispatch i think it
was like yesterday they were like oh if you look oh do you
see anything funny when you because like you know how
everyone has their own like um id um so one of my friends
was like told me like oh there's an easter egg uh for the
the heroes for the id cards and i was like like they like
send me a picture of like um i think blonde blazers id card
and they were like oh what does what do you see and then i
was like boobies like instantly yeah so yeah so like i no
hesitation and then my friend was like how did you know that
fast and i'm like because chat keeps sending me passwords
every time i ask for a password chat would be like boobs and
I'm like it's not boobs and then my chat would be like
boobies so I recognize instantly whenever I see the numbers
I can instantly tell if you guys fucking type me boobies or
boobs like so I can I'm like oh yeah that's boobies like you
guys every time I can now instantly spot boobies right away
if I It's not gonna work.
What do you mean?
It's not boobs.
One day, it's going to be.
Well, I hope you guys become a successful game developer and
sneak that one in for whatever AAA or successful indie game
is going to be.
That's your goal.
To make a password where it'll actually be boobies for once.
Or boobs.
good luck dragons good luck i will
anyway guys i'm gonna call it here oh my gosh i think oh man
i thought like it'd be a short stream because i only had
like three episodes but um we i think i think it was because
of the coop mission oh my god the coop mission was actually
fucking terrible um but i'm gonna call it here everyone time
hanging out with me as always um i always have a fun time
with everyone here and that you enjoyed my playthrough of
dispatch um i did enjoy going through this game it was very
interesting the story was very interesting um there's a lot
of fun choices and everything and you know this i think that
the gameplay of being like a dispatcher is such a you know
it's a unique concept that i enjoy very much um because you
know um we have to figure out you know okay not the rng part
rng was so fucked i the rng was definitely really fucked but
like i still had a great time um patro acid thank you a
super chat thank you thank you mark my words if our next
doki fanging ships sometime this century boobies will be a
password to unlock things early thank you super chat thank
you thank you i know how ceo feels now invincible no wonder
he like hates everyone i understand now any guys um as
always everybody say hydrated posture check get up and move
around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me
head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next
time everybody bye guys bye also cryptic thank you super
chat thank you thank you so joki when will we get your
dispatch sona and how many fangs will they have it's just be
me like it's just be this like look if i like look if i save
10 of the city that's a pass for me any guys i'll see you
guys next oh yeah by the way i can't believe it i just
realized only 30 of the city survived but i still passed
that's crazy like that's crazy like 70 of la is literally
gone and i'm like we did it guys we fucking did it anyway
bye everyone bye